Hallo, hallo, hallo.
G-Baited, korrekt.
Massive G-Bait.
Mein Fahrrad ist immer noch nicht da.
DHL schreibt jetzt seit drei Tagen, dass es im, Moment, Moment, wie heißt das?
Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken.
Im Zielverteilzentrum oder sowas.
Moment, lass mich mal kurz schauen.
DHL sagt, die Sendung ist in der Region des Empfängers angekommen
und wird im nächsten Schritt zur Zustellbasis transportiert.
Das sagen die jetzt schon seit drei Tagen.
Ich bestelle ein Fahrrad vor dem Winter, warum nicht?
Das Beste ist, das ist eigentlich so wie bei vielem,
wenn man Bock hat mit irgendwas anzufangen, macht es gleich
und schiebt das nicht irgendwie auf,
weil man glaubt gar nicht, wie gut die Sache schon immer ein halbes Jahr später läuft,
wenn das was für einen ist.
Vielleicht stellt man auch fest, das ist nichts für einen.
Dr. Pronu, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, also keine Ahnung, was mir DHL damit sagen will,
dass es dreimal jetzt schon in der Region des Empfängers angekommen ist.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass das Paket nur einmal in der Region des Empfängers ankommen könnte.
Es ist dann einfach die ganze Zeit noch in der Region des Empfängers da.
Naja, gut, man weiß nicht, was DHL da treibt.
Das ist nicht mal aktuell.
Da gibt es neuere Streams, muss man im Archiv gucken,
wo ich richtig echtes Achtzeichen,
Arch-Linux, by the way, installiere
und nicht so Fake-Arch-Linux wie Manjaro.
Fake-Arch ist nicht mehr angesagt.
Echtes Arch, by the way.
Nur dann kann man sich echt echter Arch-Linux-User...
Du meinst, der fährt mein Fahrrad zu mir heim?
Ja, das könnte natürlich sein.
Das würde es erklären, dass es ein bisschen dauert.
Wobei, so weit weg ist das gar nicht.
Ich mach mal kurz Package-Update.
Moin, Tomux.
Guck, guck, der Pepo ist auch schon kurz vor Bad-Getime.
Ja, Egel, mach mal Ausrufezeichen.
Ich glaube, Archiv oder so.
Dann findest du die Seite, wo es das Archiv gibt.
Du kannst sogar...
Moment, was?
Exa mit Eza?
What?
Moment.
Haben die sich umbenannt?
Siehste, wo wir da dabei sind?
Ein weiterer Grund, warum ich von diesen ganzen...
Wir rewriten jeden Scheiß...
...in Rust nix halte.
Ich benutze es eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich kann es jetzt gerade mal kurz removen.
Da hast du dann irgend so ein unmaintainedes Ding.
Da bleibe ich lieber beim Standard-LS.
Und mache ich ja auch.
Ich verwende das eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Wow, Alter.
Was ist denn hier los?
Was will der hier alles updaten?
Abseil.
Bester Name.
Hört sich an, als muss man kurz eine Runde Pepo-Pupu machen.
Abseil-CP.
Okay, es ist C++.
Moment.
Ist das ein Joke darauf, dass C++ so kacke ist?
Warum das so heißt?
Was ist Abseil-C++?
Okay, das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Kommt Abseilen.
Okay, was auch immer es ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Gut, dann...
Ja, dann lassen wir den nochmal updaten.
Leute, 4,4 Gig Updates.
Gib ihm.
Da wird jetzt Windows erstmal 20 Minuten für brauchen.
Aber Arch, by the way, ist da natürlich schneller.
Man sollte, man sollte Fairness-Halber sagen.
Pac-Man ist da schneller.
Und danach müssen wir noch die ganzen User-Repos updaten.
Wie war eigentlich das Meeting, wo du extra hingefahren bist?
Was war das?
Ach, das.
Du meinst, du meinst letzte Woche.
Letzte Woche Freitag.
Ja, du meinst das Top-Secret-Meeting, wo ich nichts zu erzählen darf.
Ja.
Ja, das hat alles funktioniert.
Aber Top-Secret.
Chat.
Ihr dürft nichts erzählen, ne?
Noch nicht mal, dass es das gegeben hat.
Aber ich weiß ja, sowas ist sicher bei euch.
Öffentlich im Internet ist das eigentlich immer das Beste, sowas zu sagen.
Ne, deswegen kann ich euch da auch nichts Großartiges drüber erzählen.
Aber es war nichts, also nichts super Spannendes, ja.
Ich hab da ein paar Sachen getippt.
Ja, eine Sache kann ich euch erzählen, das ist nicht, das ist nicht geheim, Top-Secret.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich, werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr erleben.
Dass es nochmal passiert.
Und zwar, guck mal hier.
Update fertig.
4,4 Gig.
Und zwar, ich musste bei diesem Top-Secret-Geheim-Meeting, musste ich ein paar Sachen eintippen.
Und das eine war ein bisschen längere, kryptische Zeichenfolge.
Und ich hab irgendwie gefühlt, was weiß ich, wie viel das waren, 160 Zeichen oder so.
Ohne zu sehen, was ich tippe.
Fehlerfrei eingetippt.
Und danach haben die Leute applaudiert.
Und dann haben die Leute applaudiert.
Ich hab tatsächlich für 160 Zeichen.
Und dann hab ich einen kleinen Tippen-Applaus bekommen.
Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Hab ich auch gesagt, okay, das war jetzt, einmal erlebt, nie wieder wird das passieren, ey.
Gang, wait.
Hat das was, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, nein, nein, nichts, nichts mit Twitch.
Du musst das Protokoll schreiben.
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Ich, je nach Meeting, finde ich das gar nicht so schlimm.
Als Azubi habe ich immer freiwillig Protokoll geschrieben.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was mich da geritten hat.
Warum?
Ach so.
Kann sagen, warum geht's denn weiter.
Als Azubi habe ich immer freiwillig, habe ich immer gerne freiwillig Protokoll geschrieben.
Ich glaube, das, das war eine meiner üblichen Taktiken, um unangenehmen Sachen aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Vermutlich.
Ich, ich, ich kann den Zusammenhang nicht mehr herstellen.
Aber ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich.
Wenn ihr wisst, dass, dass random unangenehme Sachen passieren,
dann ist es besser.
Man meldet sich freiwillig zu den unangenehmen Sachen, dann werden sie nicht so unangenehm und man hat danach Ruhe.
So, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Ich vermute mal, dass es sowas gewesen ist.
Aber ich weiß nicht mal, warum ich als Azubi so oft Protokoll, freiwillig Protokoll geschrieben habe.
An sich finde ich Protokollschreiben kacke.
So dumm vor allem.
Kennt ihr das, wenn dann irgendwelche Leute in, in irgendeiner Besprechung sitzen und sagen dann so,
ja, auf dem ABC-System ist XYZ.
Kaputt und dann hat dann der sowieso gesagt, dass B auf dem A muss, muss zu Z und ihr denkt euch dann so,
Alter, was labert ihr da eigentlich?
Was weiß ich, was soll ich denn jetzt aufschreiben?
Am Anfang habe ich immer, also gerade, wo ich noch Azubi war, habe ich immer gedacht, das muss man jetzt irgendwie verstehen.
Aber mittlerweile habe ich kapiert, dass man das eigentlich gar nicht verstehen kann.
Deswegen ist das einfachste, wenn man Protokoll schreibt, einfach danach zu fragen so, okay, schön, dass ihr jetzt Bescheid wisst.
Aber was schreibe ich denn ins Protokoll dafür?
Und oftmals kommt dann als Antwort, ach, lass raus, ist nicht so relevant.
Das ist immer das Geilste.
Wenn dann teilweise 20 Minuten über irgendwas wild diskutiert wird, du fragst dann, ja, wie schreiben wir, was schreiben wir da ins Protokoll?
Ach nee, ach nee, äh, lass mal, lass mal, kein, kein Protokoll.
Leute, irgendwas stimmt mit der Linux-VM nicht.
Die ist langsamer als sonst.
Was ist denn das?
Ich, ich spüre das, ich spüre das.
Irgendwas, Kernel-Update oder so, hat es zerstört?
Irgendwas ist da richtig langsam gerade.
Was ist denn da los?
Lass, lass mal, lass mal was checken.
Wobei.
Ha, ha, ha, habt ihr es gesehen?
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Habt ihr es stocken gesehen?
Ja, ja, guck mal.
Das hat alle, guck mal, so alle, alle 10 Sekunden hat es den Hänger.
Es ist die, ja, guck mal, guck mal.
Es ist die Frage, ob das, ob das Tastatur-Input ist.
Oh, und, und.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Guck mal, meine Statusbar ist auch kaputt.
Ja, da habe ich natürlich richtig Bock drauf jetzt.
Äh.
Boah.
Erstmal muss ich meine Status...
Oh, das, Alter, ist das...
What the...
Oh, das ist ja hyper-laggy gerade, dieses, das...
Die VM.
Ich, ich glaube, ich, ich glaube, ich muss mal Kernel down-cranen.
Da ist irgendwas, irgendwas ist da kaputt.
Äh, warum...
Das ist bestimmt mein Shell-Plugin, was nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ja, nice, da sind wir wieder.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir erstmal Kernel down-cranen machen.
Alter, ist das laggy, what the fuck?
Habe ich, habe ich...
Ne, habe ich bestimmt nicht.
Down-cranen, ne.
Wie down-cranen wir überhaupt einen Kernel unter Arch-Linux?
Habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ne, wir installieren, ich weiß, wir installieren einfach den LTS-Kernel und dann ist gut.
LTS, bam.
Zack.
Einfach, wir installieren den LTS-Kernel, der wird wahrscheinlich wieder besser funktionieren.
Ich glaube, das hat bei Linux wirklich niemand bisher behauptet.
Reboot, ich habe doch rebooted gerade.
Die Guest-Tools, die sind auf jeden Fall aktiv, sonst hätte ich nicht Fullscreen.
Sonst hätte ich nicht Fullscreen-Video und würde hier...
So, wir rebooten einfach mal schnell den LTS-Kernel und dann sollte, sollte besser funktionieren.
Alter, ist das lahm, das ist ultra laggy.
Oh ne, Leute, ich habe System Deboot.
Wie heißt das? System Deboot? Die oder sowas oder so?
Wie stellt man da überhaupt die...
Okay, Leute, Premiere, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Wir sollten mal einen Snapshot... Guck mal, wie lange das hängt.
Wir sollten an der Stelle mal einen Snapshot machen, ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Oh, ich habe noch einen Snapshot vom 22.8.
Ja, den kann ich löschen.
Snapshot vom 22.8.
Ist unsinnig.
Ich muss... Okay, wie macht man in...
Das muss man jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Wie macht man...
Wie macht man in System Deboot...
Boot D?
Wie stellt man da einen LTS-Kernel ein?
Moin, Veganer NicoTM.
Leute, ich werde noch zum richtigen Weep langsam.
Ich habe jetzt, ich habe jetzt die...
Letzte Woche über drei verschiedene Animes geguckt.
Bald ist, bald ist Weep-Time angesagt.
Normalerweise, ich habe früher nie Animes geguckt.
Aber witzig ist, ich gucke nichts Actionreiches.
Ich gucke so, ich gucke so ultrabelangloses Wohlfühlzeug irgendwie.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert mit System Deboot.
Kann... Ich weiß nicht.
Wir fragen, wir fragen das Archie-Nux-Wiki.
Das weiß man, so war es eigentlich immer Bescheid.
Alter, ist das laggy? Was ist denn da los?
Sailor Moon, nein, nein.
Mit Debian wäre das nicht passiert.
Das ist richtig, das stimmt.
Mit Debian hätte ich zwar die Hälfte der Software nicht,
aber korrekt, mit Debian wäre das nicht passiert.
Okay, System Deboot.
Heißt das Boot D? Wie heißt denn das?
Guck mal hier, Archie-Nux.
Archie-Nux.
Also, Install.
Moment, Moment.
Bevor ich an meinem Bootloader rumfuddle,
machen wir erstmal einen Snapshot.
Eines der weiteren Riesenvorteile von VMs.
Boot-CTL-Install.
Das habe ich ja wahrscheinlich.
Installation using X-Boot-LDR.
Ne, ne, installiert habe ich es doch schon.
Updating.
Update.
Okay, das erscheint mir super typisch System D.
Versteht Kassau, wie das so sein.
ESP-Loader-Conf.
Ist der Loader das, was im Boot-Menü drin steht?
Okay, wählen wir mal root.
CD-Boot.
Und dann Loader.
Loader-Conf.
Ne, das ist, Alter, das ist ultra-laggy.
Loader?
Entries?
Srell?
Was ist das denn?
Type 1, okay, alles klar.
Obviously.
Chat, ich hoffe, jedem ist klar, was Type 1 bedeutet.
Das ist so offensichtlich, das muss ich jetzt nicht erklären.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Created-by-Arch-Installer am 21.01.
Okay, ich werde mir das mal kopieren.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich hier mache.
Ich kopiere das mal.
Und nennen wir es mal Linux-LTS-Conf.
So, Linux.
Ja gut, aber wie lade ich denn jetzt mein LTS-Zeug?
Was habe ich in Boot alles drin liegen?
Ach, guck mal, minus LTS, minus LTS.
Minus LTS, minus LTS, äh, minus LTS.
Arch-Linux-LTS, ups, oh, äh, LTS, LITS-LTS.
Das Wallpaper ist POG, das kannst du auch verwenden, wenn du willst, das gibt es öffentlich auf GitHub.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, wenn ich jetzt reboote, sind dann die Einträge schon geändert?
Guck mal, wie das laggt, das ist ja nicht normal.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt, Chat, was meint ihr?
Steht jetzt LTS zur Auswahl oder nicht?
Okay, ich, what?
Das war ein bisschen schnell.
Also die Boot-Menü-Auswahl war vielleicht etwas zu, zu quick, ja.
Da muss ich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Tastatur spammen.
Okay, ich spamme jetzt einfach die Up-and-Down, die Up-and-Down-Taste in meiner 4M, dann sollte ich.
Ah, easy, LTS.
POG.
Guck mal, wie viel schneller das ist, seht ihr das?
Und jetzt, und jetzt laggt auch nichts mehr.
Ja.
Fixed.
LTS-Kernel.
Okay, wir müssen warten, bis es einen neuen Kernel gibt, dass meine 4M nicht mehr ruckelt.
Nice.
Guck mal hier, jetzt laggt nichts mehr.
Guck mal hier.
Muss den Kernel nicht anzeigen, das ist auf jeden Fall ein LTS-Kernel.
Das ist komplett, das ist ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht.
Hier laggt nichts mehr, alles flüssig.
Was war der Fix für den Lag?
LTS-Kernel installieren, der neue Kernel.
Der neueste Kernel hat irgendwelche Schmerzen in meiner 4M.
So ist das halt, wenn man Pleading Edge Arch Linux, by the way, benutzt.
Ne, guck, keinerlei Lags.
Okay, sehr schön.
Und jetzt mal Updates hinterher.
Sehr gut.
6.1 LTS, das wird's gewesen sein.
Die Rust, das Rust-Feature hat das Lag verursacht.
Sehr schön.
So.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Ja, ja.
Was?
Wie was?
Du hattest das auch in Manjaro, hast du das auch in der 4M?
Was hältst du von Immutable Betriebssystem?
Hm.
Hab ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich mein, in Zeiten von Containerisierung und möglichst,
sagen wir mal, Immutable Infrastruktur und eher Config-Änder neu aufbauen,
ist das irgendwie ein logischer Schritt,
für tägliche Arbeit bin ich mir da nicht so sicher, ob das der Weisheitsletzterschluss ist.
Was für Animes ich geguckt habe?
Okay, also, ich hab zuerst geguckt die zweite Staffel von, äh, wie heißt,
ich weiß nicht, wie das auf Japanisch heißt, äh, Jobless, äh, äh, fuck, wie heißt das, ähm,
nicht Resurrection, Jobless Reincarnation, hab ich geguckt, die zweite Staffel.
Wie gesagt, ich, ich werd noch zum Ultra Weep hier, ich sag's euch.
Dann hab ich geguckt, ähm, wie hieß das?
I maxed out my levels while killing slimes for 300 years oder irgendwie sowas.
Fragt mich nicht, wer sich diese Titel ausdenkt.
Und, und dann hab ich geguckt, Kobayashi.
Kobayashi's Dragon Maid.
Übelst, Leute, fragt mich nicht, das sind alles übelst so, wie, wie, wie nennt man das so, so, so cute Zeug.
Weiß nicht, warum mir das, warum mir das gerade so zusagt.
Das ist, das ist super, das ist super entspannend, alles zu gucken, weil da passiert nix Schlimmes.
Das kannst du dir angucken und denkst so, ja, die Welt ist in Ordnung und so.
Weiß nicht, ich sag euch, Leute, ich werd hier noch zum Weeps in Shonen.
Ja, das hab ich, hab ich gehört.
Aber eigentlich bin ich gar nicht so der Riesen-Anime-Gucker.
Aber so die letzten paar Wochen hab ich tatsächlich recht viel geguckt in der Richtung.
So.
Nur eins muss ich sagen, so der japanische Humor, der zündet noch nicht so wirklich.
Da muss man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen.
Also, also was mir aufgefallen ist.
Die Japaner finden das super lustig, wenn irgendwas, irgendwas Blödes passiert und, und sich einer dann gefühlt zwei Stunden lang entschuldigt und von allen dafür, dafür angeschrien wird.
So, so diese Szenen gibt es in allen möglichen wiederkehrenden Varianten, ne.
Das scheint so eine typische Japan-Humor-Geschichte zu sein.
Keine Ahnung, ich, ich, also damit werde ich auch nicht so wirklich warm mit manchen Sachen, wo ich mir denke, okay.
Also, super lustig war das jetzt nicht.
Aber dafür ist, dafür ist die Welt irgendwie, wenn man sich die richtigen Sachen anguckt, in Ordnung.
Wahrscheinlich ähnlich, wie wenn meine Mutter im ZDF Rosamunde Pilcher guckt, gucke ich mir irgendwelche cute Animes an.
Dann, dann ist die Welt in Ordnung, ja.
Was wird gemacht?
Nix.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit dem Titel los ist, ja.
Die Titel sind teilweise drei Seiten lang.
Äh, bestimmt nicht.
Wie gesagt, normal bin ich eigentlich kein großer Anime-Gucker, zumindest bis jetzt.
Ja, kein großer Anime-Gucker.
Vielleicht, vielleicht waren die Sachen, Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Ah, vielleicht, vielleicht war, so, so, so, V, danke schön für den Sub.
Vielleicht waren die Sachen, die ich bisher in der Vergangenheit mal immer so ein bisschen Probe geguckt habe, einfach nicht mein Genre, keine Ahnung.
Hat mir nie so sonderlich zugesagt.
Hm, also die letzten paar, die ich geguckt habe, fand ich ganz nice.
Naja, ich, ich kann halt mit diesem ganzen übertriebenen...
5000 verschiedenen Attacken und...
Ah, wie soll man das beschreiben, so...
So, oh, ich wurde verletzt.
Aber, ha, ha, ha, ich habe nicht mit voller Kraft gekämpft, sowas.
Damit kann ich ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig anfangen.
Also ich hab, ich hab bisher nichts auf Deutsch geguckt.
Hm.
Den einen habe ich auf Englisch geguckt und die anderen auf Japanisch mit Untertitel.
Weil das echt anstrengend ist, da gewöhnt man sich aber wahrscheinlich mit der Zeit dran, oder?
Untertitel lesen.
Zumal man sagen muss, die Story ist bei den meisten jetzt nicht so super komplex,
dass man da...
gar nicht mitkommt, wenn man auch nur so, so...
Also es reicht eigentlich, wenn man so ein paar Wörter in den Untertitel liest und dann versteht man schon...
versteht man eigentlich meistens, worum es geht.
Igel, danke für den Sub.
So.
Oh!
Besos muss ins Weltall, Leute.
Der Scam Train ist am Start.
Was war das für eine Frage hier oben?
Irgendwas, irgendwas habe ich gerade gelesen.
Was?
Kann man bei Hetzner einfach eine Windows 10 Anwendung laufen lassen, auf die ich von überall zugreifen kann,
äh, um es wie ein Desktop zu verwenden?
Das kannst du...
Also einfach eine Anwendung kannst du nicht laufen lassen.
Du kannst dir einen Windows Server in der Cloud kaufen und darauf was laufen lassen,
das kannst du mit RDP verwenden wie einen Desktop, aber halt wie ein bisschen laggy Desktop.
RDP ist halt laggy.
Ich meine, okay, X-Forwarding ist noch deutlich mehr laggy, aber trotzdem...
Das ist nicht zu vergleichen mit irgendeinem Game Streaming Service,
Service von der Latenz
oder so.
Es ist auch ehrlich gesagt nicht dafür
gedacht, Desktop-Anwendungen
laufen zu lassen. Also könntest du machen, ist aber
wahrscheinlich keine allzu schlaue Idee.
Zumal das Ding auch public im Internet erreichbar
sein müsste.
Dementsprechend, um es sicher zu machen,
müsstest du wahrscheinlich noch ein VPN bauen.
Da nicht. Also wenn du sowas haben
willst, ich glaube Microsoft selbst hat
mittlerweile Windows Cloud
Windows VMs. Die wohl
auch mit
Hardware Acceleration
und verbessertem RDP und so
funktionieren, möglichst latenzfrei.
Habe ich aber noch nicht ausprobiert. Keine Ahnung, wie das
so ist. Just Marv, danke
für den Sub.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Heute zeigt einfach
Mist an.
Ja, das stimmt.
Deswegen finde ich SSH halt pock.
SSH ist halt schön
per default sicher.
Okay.
Datenbank mit Anwendungen.
Wie sinnvoll aufbauen.
Drei Anwendungen
mit je einer DB.
DBs auf VMs laufen lassen und von außen drauf
connecten oder alle DBs zu einer
migraten.
Und dann
mit Nutzern von außen drauf,
wo jeder Nutzer nur seine DB sehen kann.
So hundertprozentig habe ich es noch
nicht kapiert.
Dir geht es im Prinzip darum, ob du
eine fette
Datenbankkiste hinstellst.
Wo dann die Anwendung
jeweils drei, also eine
fette Datenbank
Instanz
VM und da drin
dann für jede Anwendung eine Datenbank anlegen.
Kann man machen.
Also wenn das
alles zu einem Service gehört und man es
einfach haben will, kann man das ohne Probleme auch
so machen.
Es ist schwer zu sagen, was da pauschal
besser ist.
Ich meine,
Backup mäßig und so nimmt sich das nix.
Weil du kannst die Datenbanken, auch wenn die alle in einer
liegen.
Unterschiedlich unterschiedlich Backupen wie du willst und
Restore also ich ich persönlich würde wahrscheinlich.
Schwer zu sagen, es kommt kommt bisschen drauf an.
Also wenn du da jetzt irgendwie keine super hoch verfügbaren
Anforderungen dran hast ja oder du irgendwie
Performance Probleme kriegst, weil die alle super krass
viel Datenbank verursachen.
Würde ich tatsächlich alles mehr oder weniger auf eine, also wenn's
muss halt Sachen, also wenn das jetzt irgendwie so was kleines ist,
Hobby mäßig ist von dir, dann nimmst nimm eine VM und hau alle drei
Anwendungen drauf, inklusive Datenbank fertig, da würde ich mir gar
keine Gedanken zu machen.
So, wenn das.
Was Business mäßiges ist, dann würde ich tatsächlich ganz anders
machen.
Dann würde ich gar keine Datenbank selbst betreiben, sondern mir eine
Managed Datenbank irgendwo holen.
Dann muss ich mich nämlich nicht um die Datenbank großartig kümmern,
was Updates vom OS und sonst was angeht.
Und Backups sind auch easy as fuck zu machen.
Aber natürlich muss ich ein bisschen mehr bezahlen.
Hat aber den Vorteil, du musst dich halt um nix kümmern.
Es soll alles im Haus bleiben.
Kann man.
Ich glaub, man kann das pauschal nicht sagen.
Also wenn das was ich würde wahrscheinlich dann eher danach gehen.
Wie intern die.
Das Management von den Anwendungen gehandhabt wird, also sprich.
Wie sehr macht's Probleme, wenn die Anwendungen von drei unterschiedlichen
Teams betreut werden mit unterschiedlichen Release Zyklen und allem, wenn das alles auf einer.
Wenn das alles auf einer.
Großen Datenbank zusammenläuft.
Ich mein eigentlich in der Theorie sollten sollte das ja nix machen.
Das hängt ja alles nicht zusammen, obwohl es in der gleichen läuft, aber vielleicht gibt's ja doch mal irgendwelche
Wartungsarbeiten, wo dann die zentrale Vm runtergefahren werden muss und die einen sagen ja, unsere Anwendung darf nur ab
Mitternacht stehen.
Die anderen sagen, das darfst du auch tagsüber machen und die nächsten kommen an.
Ja, ab zwei Uhr nachts ist okay, also wenn es da so organisatorische Probleme gibt, dann ist vielleicht besser, man macht drei.
Einzelne Kisten.
Handhabungstechnisch würde ich sagen, ist wahrscheinlich das das angenehmste, eine Datenbank zu haben und je nachdem, wie das Management der Kisten ist, bietet sich vielleicht auch an, die ganzen Anwendungen selbst auf eine Vm zu machen.
Eventuell mit ein bisschen Ha.
Aber je nachdem, was es ist, braucht ihr das vielleicht auch gar nicht.
Aber benutze.
Damit nicht jeder was sehen kann.
Na ja, jeder kann ja gar nichts sehen.
Weil die Leute gehen ja nicht direkt auf die Datenbank, die gehen ja auf deinen auf deinen Web Backend an eine Web API.
Gut, du kannst jetzt natürlich sagen, okay, wenn du eine Sicherheitslücke in deinem in deiner Backend Software hast.
Dann könnte man theoretisch auf Daten der anderen Anwendungen darüber zugreifen, wenn man irgendwelche SQL Sachen drüber ausführen kann.
Ja, dann musst du gucken, dass du deine Berechtigung in der Datenbank so vergibst, dass der.
Eine das andere nicht lesen kann.
Das ist aber gar kein Ding.
Also das ist wirklich kein Problem.
Also ich weiß es nur in Postgres.
In Postgres ist das ziemlich einfach.
Datenbank User anzulegen und Berechtigung zu vergeben.
Übrigens auch schön, wenn du eine Managed Datenbank hättest, kannst du das direkt, wenn du per Terraform aufbaust oder über das jeweilige Cloud Web Frontend machen.
Oh, was mit dem Chat geht los?
Willkommen im Chat.
Okay.
Warum hat er Nightbot Overwatch 2019?
Warte, Moment.
Als Nachteil von flachen Hierarchien.
Boah, jetzt sind aber die Five Head Questions am Start, oder?
Ähm.
Sehe ich da irgendwelche Nachteile?
Dass alle einem auf den Sack gehen.
Ähm.
Keine Ahnung.
Erfällt mir jetzt so spontan.
Also ich ganz ehrlich, hättest du mich das Umgedrehte gefragt.
Was siehst du als Vorteil von flachen Hierarchien, wenn ich genauso überlegen müssen?
Ich glaube, man muss sich als erstes mal Gedanken drüber machen, ab wann ist eine Hierarchie flach?
Was ist denn, was ist denn für dich eine flache Hierarchie?
So nach dem Motto, ähm, sobald es mehr als zwei Ebenen gibt, mehr als drei?
Oder, oder wie ist das?
Also, ich mein, dort, wo ich bisher gearbeitet habe und dort, wo ich jetzt arbeite, ist es eigentlich relativ ähnlich.
Dann würde ich sagen, es ist nicht übertrieben mit Hierarchien, aber es gibt halt recht sinnvoll.
Aufgeteilte Sachen.
Also, bei uns ist es so, wir haben einen Teamleiter.
Der ist, der hat dann vielleicht verschiedene Untergruppchen, die haben aber keine eigenen Leiter mehr.
Also beispielsweise bei uns, wir haben ein Team für Linux, ein Team für Storage und ein Team für Windows.
Jeweils mit, so Leute sind wir so sieben Stück oder so.
Also sagen wir mal, so um die, so plus, minus, so in dem Dreh, so um die 20 Leute.
Wir haben ein Team, da drüber gibt's dann einen Abteilungsleiter IT.
Äh, das stimmt nicht, da drüber, nein, nein, nein, da drüber gibt's dann einen Abteilungsleiter für IT-Infrastruktur.
Und da drüber gibt es noch einen IT-Abteilungsleiter, frag mich nicht, wie man das dann nennt.
Also, das würde ich nicht sagen, dass das flach ist, aber ich find's eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, vor allem halt auch bei der Größe.
Also das, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das so sieht.
Ob das so sinnig ist.
Ich mein, es hat sicherlich seine Vorteile, dass, also ich kann jetzt auch nur raten, also sowas, sowas hatte ich noch nicht,
dass du Teams hast und darüber kommt das CEO, so nach dem Motto.
Und du hast Teams, Teamleiter, CEO.
Also das hatte ich in der, in der, naja doch, doch, damals als ich beim Internetprovider gearbeitet hab, war das so, aber das war ja auch, wie viel hatten wir da, 200, 250 Leute oder so, Mitarbeiter.
Ja, da hatten wir unterschiedliche Teams.
Also Teamleiter und danach kamen eigentlich schon die Chefs.
Ja.
Was war da der Vorteil von?
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich keinen gesehen, weil die, weil die mir extrem auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Ich mein, man kriegt vieles schneller mit.
Das mag vielleicht eines der Vorteile sein.
Beziehungsweise ungeschönter.
Das ist vielleicht auch eines der Nachteile von so bisschen komplexeren Hierarchien, dass vieles gefiltert wird von unten nach oben und von oben nach unten.
In der Hierarchie-Ebene.
Wenn's die da, also wenn's die Ebenen dazwischen verkacken.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Fällt, ich, fällt mir echt nichts ein zu gerade.
PDE versus IDE.
Wollen die mir sagen, ein Personal Developed Environment versus ein Integrated, was auch immer.
Die Leute machen da immer eine Wissenschaft draus.
Das reimt ja auf keinen Stream, ich würd sagen ein Stream, oder?
Und was, was muss man generell, was reimt sich auf Stream?
Meme.
Weiß ich, keine Ahnung.
Stream. Keine Ahnung.
Scream.
Stream.
Beam. Team.
Beam auch.
Stream. Meme.
Meme reimt sich auch, oder?
Stream und Meme? Naja, nicht wirklich.
Nee, nicht, nicht wirklich gut, oder?
Stream, Meme, naja.
Naja, sehr, sehr halbherzig.
Halbherzig.
Sonst fällt mir nix mehr ein.
Fragen, fragen wir doch mal.
Stream, Reimen.
Okay.
Was reimt sich auf Stream?
Alter.
Was ist das für ein Vorschlag?
Was reimt sich auf Stream?
Naziregime.
Was ist das für eine Seite, Mann?
Also, das wäre das letzte, woran ich gedacht hätte.
Was reimt sich auf Stream, Alter?
Merkwürdige Seite, Alter.
Chat, müsst ihr zugeben, da hättet ihr jetzt auch nicht dran gedacht, dass sich das da drauf reimt.
Reimt sich besser als wie.
Naja.
Moin, Anpil.
Irgendwelche Subs übersehen?
Habe ich übersehen?
Anpil, dankeschön für den Sub.
Weißt du, woran ich das gesehen habe, dass ich wahrscheinlich was übersehen habe?
Weil ich habe deinen Namen hier relativ selten gesehen.
Habe aber gesehen, okay, du hast einen Kick.
Moment.
Hat der eben gerade subscri...
Du hast schon öfters mal...
Das ist der zweite Monat schon.
Habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Mav, POG Subscription hier.
Ah.
Gut, da kann ich meine 4M mal wieder ausmachen.
Übrigens, letztens, jemand bei uns auf der Arbeit...
Hat gemeint, er fährt Server nur runter mit Init...
Keine Ahnung, was muss man dafür überhaupt machen?
Init 0 oder ist das Reboot?
Init 5?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da mit einem Server runterfährt, ehrlich gesagt.
Und...
Bis ich dann rausgekriegt habe, dass der früher reiner Solaris-Admin war.
Und da macht man das wohl so.
Weiß ich nicht, ich...
Was war...
Was, Init 5 ist Reboot?
Nee, Init 5 ist grafische Oberfläche, okay.
Und was ist...
Okay...
Init Reboot?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Init 6 ist Reboot.
Okay.
Init 6...
Macht nichts.
Okay.
Init 0...
Macht auch nichts.
Okay.
Nice.
Artstealungs, by the way.
Halt?
Wirklich?
Tatsächlich?
Ha!
Oh.
CPU has been disabled.
Okay, alles klar.
Jetzt hat meine 4M den Geist aufgegeben.
Also, ehrlich gesagt...
Ich benutze nur Power-Off und Reboot und an was anderes...
Aha.
Ja, das ergibt natürlich Sinn.
Oh nein!
Ich habe wieder meinen verpackten Kernel geladen.
Wo stellt man denn hier bei SystemD um, dass der...
Dass der den richtigen lädt?
Warte mal.
Boot?
Loader?
Loader-Conf vielleicht?
Timer 3 ist okay.
Tja, wo stellt man hier den Default ein?
Entries?
Tja...
Das weiß ich nicht, wie das geht.
Dann reboote ich jetzt nochmal und starte den LTS-Kernel.
Ist das laggy mit diesem...
Was backt da so rum?
Crap.
Das ist kein Crap.
Das ist SystemD-Boot.
Ich habe mir da bisher noch nie Gedanken drum gemacht, aber bei Crap hätte ich es gewusst,
wie das funktioniert.
Aber SystemD-Boot-D oder wie sich das nennt, da weiß ich das nicht.
Max, machst du eigentlich jetzt eher Linux in der Cloud oder ist das Zeug sehr...
Ich mache zu 95% Linux Cloud.
Aktuell zumindest.
Wir haben aber auch relativ viele Systeme noch on Prem, wie die coolen Leute das sagen,
stehen.
Da mache ich auch ab und zu was, aber aktuell ist es 95% Cloud.
Und davon tatsächlich auch Linux nur so quasi von der...
Also von der Zuständigkeit her.
Es sind zwar letztendlich Linux-Kisten, aber es ist hauptsächlich...
Also Linux-Kisten unten drunter, aber es ist hauptsächlich Kubernetes oder sehr viel
Terraform in letzter Zeit für Infrastruktur aufzubauen.
Natürlich baut das dann oftmals Linux-Kisten auf, aber mit denen habe ich dann gar nicht
so viel zu tun.
Ja.
Ich muss halt...
Ich muss denen auch mal alle beibringen, wie man richtig diagonal skaliert.
Die skalieren glaube ich nur horizontal aktuell.
Und die müssen auch mal lernen, wie das richtig geht.
Wie dreidimensional diagonal skaliert wird.
So wie sich das gehört.
Wenn man richtiger 5-Head-Cloud-Native sein möchte.
Stonks.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Stimmt.
Das Video wurde mir eben empfohlen auf YouTube.
Das gucke ich mir jetzt mal an.
Microsoft sagt nämlich...
Dass es jetzt einen Co-Pilot für Windows 11 gibt.
Das ist glaube ich Teil von dem, was wir uns letztens angeguckt haben.
Aber wir gucken uns mal das offizielle Werbevideo von Microsoft dafür an.
Wahrscheinlich, um festzustellen, dass es wieder irgendein halbherziger Schrott am Ende
ist.
Aber man weiß ja nie so genau.
Lass uns mal die 1 Minute 40 oder wie lang es...
1 Minute 51 mal kurz checken.
Was ist eigentlich horizontal und diagonal skalieren?
Skalieren klar, aber horizontal und diagonal...
Also.
Ich versuche das mal zu erklären.
Horizontal skalieren.
Ich bringe das immer ein bisschen durcheinander.
Ich versuche mich mal zu konzentrieren, dass ich es nicht falsch herum wieder erzähle.
Also.
Wenn man von skalieren bei Infrastruktur spricht.
Dann gibt es hauptsächlich 2 verschiedene Sachen, die man machen kann.
Das eine ist horizontal skalieren.
Und das andere ist vertikal skalieren.
Mit horizontal skalieren ist gemeint.
Man startet die Anwendung.
Auf mehreren...
Also mal angenommen, du hast eine Anwendung, die du betreiben willst.
Es gibt mehr User.
Nächsten Monat noch mehr User, noch mehr User, noch mehr User.
Oder du hast morgens viele User, abends keine.
Also es fluktuiert relativ stark.
Und da hast du jetzt die Auswahl.
Okay, was mache ich?
Da kannst du zum Beispiel sagen, ich skaliere horizontal.
Das bedeutet, du startest die Anwendung einfach mehrfach.
Also du skalierst das in die Breite.
Und wenn dir die Hardware nicht mehr ausreicht mit den CPU-Cores.
Dann stellst du eine zweite Hardware daneben.
Zum Beispiel im Kubernetes-Cluster.
Einen weiteren Cluster-Node.
Daneben startest du die Anwendung mehrfach.
Also du gehst quasi in die Breite.
Das nennt man horizontal skalieren.
Vertikal skalieren wäre das Gegenteil davon.
Du machst die Kiste, auf der die Anwendung läuft, fetter.
Du upgradest die.
Du gibst dir 128 GB RAM.
Und noch 2 CPUs mehr.
Das wäre vertikal skalieren.
So.
Und nachdem das ja jeder kann.
Und wir hier im Stream pfeifert sind.
Skalieren wir einfach diagonal.
Das ist nichts, was es in der Wirklichkeit gibt.
Das ist einfach was, was ich mir hier ausgedacht habe.
Aber du kannst damit sicherlich die ein oder anderen Consultants verwirren, wenn du die das fragst.
Weil Consultants haben ja immer so diese...
Diese allwissende Aura.
Die sie sich gerne andichten wollen.
So nach dem Motto.
Ich weiß das schon.
Und du kannst ja mal einen Consultant fragen.
Ob er dann auch Lösungen fürs diagonale skalieren anbieten kann.
Und da bringt man bestimmt den ein oder anderen ins Schwimmen.
Weil er keine Ahnung mehr hat, was du eigentlich meinst.
Naja, kann man nicht horizontal und vertikal skalieren.
Weil man ja nicht beides...
Naja, weil du entweder horizontal skalierst oder vertikal.
Du kannst natürlich sowohl als auch...
Also du kannst auch beides machen.
Aber da hast du nicht wirklich diagonal skaliert.
Sondern du hast einmal deine Kisten erweitert.
Und noch Kisten stärker gemacht.
Also du hast einmal horizontal skaliert und dann vertikal skaliert.
Es ist nicht so, dass es wie in Paint wäre.
Wo man einfach oder in irgendeiner Bildbearbeitung so diesen Skalierungsdings hoch nach rechts oben zieht.
Und auf einmal werden deine Kisten größer und mehr.
Was ja in Paint auch nicht passiert.
Wenn man es genau nimmt.
Skaliert Paint eigentlich nur vertikal.
Also für Infrastruktur gesprochen.
Skaliert Paint nur vertikal.
Also nehmen wir mal an.
Du hast hier einen Server.
Du hast hier noch einen Server.
Wenn du jetzt in Paint sagst.
Ich hoffe das geht in Paint.
Ich skaliere das diagonal.
Dann hast du in Wirklichkeit eigentlich nur vertikal skaliert.
Weil deine Kisten fetter wurden.
Aber es wurden nicht mehr Kisten.
Also aus Infrastruktursicht ist das eigentlich nur vertikal skaliert.
Ey Max ich überlege meinen Arbeitgeber zu wechseln.
Hast du eine Idee wie ich nach einem Zwischenzeugnis fragen kann.
Oder dass es komisch ist.
Ja habe ich.
Also wenn du nicht einfach sagen willst.
Jungs ich bin schon so lange dabei.
Wie sieht es mal aus mit dem Zwischenzeugnis.
Es gibt zwei Sachen die immer ganz gut sind.
Das erste ist.
Vorgesetztenwechsel.
Und das zweite ist.
Was immer geht.
Du sagst dein Aufgabengebiet hat sich die letzten Jahre über.
Oder die letzten Monate.
Was auch immer.
Erweitert.
Verändert.
Wie auch immer.
Und nachdem wir in der IT arbeiten und laufen.
Irgendwelches neues Zeug dazu kommt.
Ist das eigentlich immer was.
Was geht.
Und dann sagst du.
Das ist das.
Und du willst ein Zwischenzeugnis haben.
Letztendlich.
Werden die immer.
Ein bisschen was wittern.
Wenn du nach einem Zwischenzeugnis fragst.
Weil niemand fragt.
Random nach einem Zwischenzeugnis.
Aber ich persönlich finde das nichts schlimmes.
Nach einem Zwischenzeugnis zu fragen.
Ja genau so sieht es aus.
Ja.
Es kommt immer auf die Anwendung an letztendlich.
Ja genau.
Es kommt letztendlich immer auf die Anwendung an.
Am besten ist.
Also im Cloud Umfeld.
Ist es.
In der Regel am besten du kannst.
Also wenn du horizontal skalieren kannst.
Da fährst du in der Regel besser.
Und wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Ecke günstiger.
Also wenn du dir ganz viele kleine VMs hinstellen kannst.
Als Nodes.
Ist das meistens besser.
Als wenn du drei vier mega super krass Fette dir hinstellst.
Die kosten.
Also unverhältnismäßig mehr.
Kannst du teilweise 800 Euro im Monat für eine VM bei Google ausgeben.
Aber die VM Preise bei Google sind eh jenseits von all dem was ich.
Privat mir leisten würde.
Also da muss ich sagen.
Das geht bestimmt.
Wenn man Glück hat.
Wenn man Pech hat nicht.
Aber.
Das.
Das Ding ist halt die.
Ist halt das.
Kommt natürlich auch immer ein bisschen auf den Arbeitgeber an.
Aber.
Das Ding ist halt das.
Selbst wenn die einen nochmal beschwätzen.
Dass man.
Noch da bleibt.
So nach dem Motto.
Ah ok.
Bevor du abhaust.
Dann geben wir dir doch ein bisschen mehr Geld.
Die Sachen die dich aufgeregt haben.
Die sind ja nachdem du mehr Geld bekommen hast nicht weg.
Und es ist selten rein das Gehalt warum man einen Arbeitgeber wechselt.
Ich mein.
Ist sicherlich eines der wichtigsten Faktoren.
Ich mein wir gehen alle arbeiten weil wir ordentlich Geld verdienen wollen.
Nicht weil wir sagen.
Ja ich mach das nur weil ich es so super geil finde.
Also natürlich ist das ein großer Punkt.
Aber die allermeisten Leute kündigen sicherlich nicht nur.
Wegen dem Gehalt.
Und weil sie woanders mehr bekommen.
Sondern das hat oftmals auch noch andere Gründe.
Weil ja bei mir.
War ja bei mir auch so.
Beim letzten Arbeitgeber.
War nicht nur das Gehalt.
War auch der Umgang mit Homeoffice.
Wo man immer wieder tolle Ankündigungen gemacht hat.
Und dann wieder Rückzieher.
Und auch das der Laden nicht aus seinem eigenen Kack den er gebaut hat.
Lernen wollte.
Und das immer schön geredet hat.
Ein paar Sachen die mich genervt haben.
Und in der Summe.
Ja und natürlich kann man woanders auch mehr verdienen.
In der Summe hat es dann dazu geführt dass ich woanders hin bin.
Und hätte ich jetzt von denen mehr Geld bekommen.
Wo sie sich ja auch nicht mal richtig zu durchringen konnten.
Weil sie irgendwie ein bisschen pepeger gewesen sind.
Den sind ja noch über 100 Leute.
Ich glaube 102 Leute angeblich weggerannt dieses Jahr.
Bis sie es dann endlich mal gecheckt haben.
Dass sie den verblieben und ein bisschen mehr Geld bezahlen müssen.
Aber selbst das hätte ja wahrscheinlich nichts gebracht.
Weil die Dinger die mich aufgeregt haben ja auch noch da waren.
Gerade der Umgang mit Homeoffice.
Der war ja auch noch da.
Der war ja nicht weg.
Auch wenn sie mir mehr Geld gegeben hätten.
Also da hätten sie mir schon extrem viel mehr Geld geben müssen.
Dass mich der Umhang.
Dass mich dieses.
Ach wir kommen jetzt einfach mal alle wieder zur.
Komplett ins Büro und solche Dinger.
Dass ich da das weiter gemacht hätte.
Da hätten sie schon sagen müssen.
Max wir bezahlen die einfach mal das Doppelte.
Da hätte ich mich vielleicht nicht mehr.
Aber selbst dann.
Selbst dann.
Es ist ja nicht so als bin ich groß auf.
Ich meine.
Ich verdiene über einen gewissen.
Level.
Wo ich sage.
Hey.
Wenn es jetzt doppelt so viel ist.
Ist nice.
Aber es ist auch nicht als müsste ich mich krass einschränken.
Wenn es das nicht ist.
Da ist es lieber.
Sie haben eine ordentliche Homeoffice Regelung noch dabei.
Das hätte mich trotz doppelt so viel Geld immer noch abgefuckt.
Und dementsprechend sind diese.
Also die sind die Probleme ja nicht weg.
Ja.
Aber ich finde den Rechner.
Da hat es nichts direkt mit den Preisen zu tun.
Ich finde den Rechner für Azure irgendwie angenehmer.
Als den Google Rechner.
Bei Google fehlt dann irgendwie immer die Hälfte.
Bei Azure bin ich meistens ganz gut mit hingekommen.
Aber der Google Rechner ist weird champ.
Nee.
Perfekt ist es nirgendwo.
Aber bei mir.
Also bei mir ist es so.
Sachen die.
Also es gibt.
Es gibt zwei Sachen.
Die mich.
Also es gibt zwei Arten von Dingern die mich nerven.
Ja.
Es gibt.
Sachen auf der Arbeit.
Die nerven mich.
Weil ich sie halt.
Unsinnig finde.
Ja.
Wie zum Beispiel.
In manchen Bereichen.
Übertriebene.
Bürokratische.
Im Kreis gelaufe Zeug.
Oder.
Was gibt es da sonst noch.
Ja.
Irgendwelche.
Irgendwelche Leute.
Die meinen.
Hier.
Wir müssen das jetzt in Pearl programmieren.
Oder was auch immer.
Ja.
Irgendwelche.
Es gibt sicherlich ein paar Sachen die mir auf den Keks gehen.
So technischer Natur.
Und sowas.
Aber das interessiert mich persönlich nicht.
Das ist nichts wo ich sagen würde.
Oh.
Da rege ich mich.
Da rege ich mich auch außerhalb der Arbeit drüber auf.
Da denke ich mir so.
Okay.
Ist es total bescheuert was in Pearl heutzutage.
Aber okay.
Macht halt wenn ihr wollt.
Ja.
Okay.
Aber.
Da gibt es die andere.
Den anderen Typ von Sachen.
Wie zum Beispiel.
Wenn angekündigt wird.
Wir sind so ein super krasser geiler moderner Arbeitgeber.
Und wir haben eine neue Homeoffice Regelung.
Unsere neue Homeoffice Regelung lautet so nach dem Motto.
Mitarbeiter first.
Und wir sind die allergeilsten.
Und.
Klärt einfach mit eurem Chef ab.
Wie man das mit Homeoffice bei euch umsetzen kann.
Und wir kommen euch dann entgegen.
Und füllt einfach nur mit eurem Chef zusammen diesen Antrag aus.
Reicht den ein.
Und dann ist alles gut.
Und sobald man den Antrag abgegeben hat.
Heißt das.
Wir lassen einfach nichts mehr von uns hören.
Und ihr kommt gefälligst wieder ins Büro.
Wir haben uns einfach nicht mehr dran erinnert.
Was wir noch vor zwei Monaten erzählt haben.
So.
Das sind dann so Sachen.
Die regen mich nicht nur in der Arbeit auf.
Die regen mich auch so weiterhin auf.
Und die gehen halt auch durch mehr Gehalt nicht weiter.
Und durch mehr Gehalt nicht weg.
Die ersten Sachen sind mir eh schon egal.
Und durch mehr Gehalt werden die mir noch egaler.
Wenn es mich nervt.
Okay.
Aber manche Sachen facken mich ab.
Und die sind.
Da ist mir auch egal wie viel Geld die mir bezahlen.
Die ärgern mich dann weiter.
Und es gibt.
Deswegen.
Perfekt.
Infern dass es nichts gibt was dich aufregt.
Das ist so.
Aber.
Es sollte wenig von diesen Typ 2 aufregend sein.
Sondern solange das alles Typ 1 aufregend ist.
Ist das okay.
Also.
Da sind wir gar nicht so weit voneinander weg.
Guck mal.
Ich habe auch noch nicht oft meinen Arbeitgeber gewechselt.
Ich habe beim Provider meine Ausbildung gemacht.
Und danach kurz da gearbeitet.
Dann bin ich gewechselt zur Bank in Frankfurt.
Da war ich jetzt eine ganze Weile.
Und jetzt bin ich zur Versicherung in Frankfurt gewechselt.
Das war es.
Okay.
Von meinen BWL Ausflügen reden wir jetzt nicht.
Das war.
Will ich nichts mehr davon wissen.
Aber.
Also ich.
Ich habe ja davor noch eine andere Ausbildung.
Also angefangen.
Angefangen.
Aber das lassen wir mal weg.
Das zählt nicht.
Und das habe ich auch nie ernsthaft gemacht.
Also ich meine.
Ich habe wenn du so willst.
Eigentlich auch nur zweimal.
Den Arbeitgeber gewechselt.
Ja.
Also für alle die es nicht wissen.
Ich habe mal Bürokaufmann angefangen zu lernen.
Und.
Habe es aber nicht weiter gemacht.
Oder besser gesagt.
Aufmann für Büroorganisation.
Ja.
Und.
DSL, O2. O2 ist doch
nur Reseller, oder?
Ja, weil das ja so gut wie
kein Stream heute ist.
Du bekommst nicht mal Überstunden gut geschrieben?
Da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das überhaupt
legal ist. Es sei denn,
es sei denn, du hast irgendwie so
Vertrauensarbeitszeit, Spezialvertrag oder
sowas, wenn du das nicht hast, dann sind
die sogar, glaube ich, verpflichtet, das, aber das
ist gefährliches Halbwissen von mir,
eine Zeiterfassung zu führen.
Ja.
Aber nicht nur
daraus, aber nicht nur daher.
Sebaso-chan!
Ah, ja, ja.
Danke für den Sub.
By the way, ich use
Arch als Hauptsystem. Endlich kein
Windorf mehr.
Kratz.
Du meinst...
Leute, Achtung,
es wird cringe.
Äh, du meinst, äh,
Mini-Weich-Windorf?
Ich find das so cringe,
diese Aussprache, Alter.
Das machen nur die ganzen
heiße Forums-Boomer,
die das so nennen. Ich find das so...
Das tut schon richtig weh
beim Aussprechen, ne.
Das ist das schlimmste
Subreddit, Mann.
Arbeitsleben. Das ist so schrecklich,
was da teilweise für ein Blödsinn geschrieben
wird auch. Bei denen ist ja
wirklich jeder Ratschlag
so, haha, bist
du dumm? Ich hab besser,
verhandelt oder oder schreibt schreibt direkt schreibt direkt kündigung und
anzeige ist raus das ist das schlimmste subreddit ja danke schön für den sub
soll ich wollte mir dieses komische video steam funktioniert auch ja es
funktioniert mittlerweile erstaunlich viel unter unter linux was gaming angeht
bis halt zu dem zeitpunkt wo es halt mal nicht funktioniert und dann hast halt
gelitten und aktuell ist eines der größten baustellen halt anti cheat da
wird sich wahrscheinlich auch auf absehbarer zeit nichts ändern aber wenn
man keine multiplayer games spielt oder keine games mit totalen wirren
kopierschützen die da probleme machen ist das sicherlich
gut nutzbar macht es sinn das frontend im kubernetes cluster zu haben eigentlich
nicht weil die natürlich macht es sinn das frontend aber im moment ist das
richtig
du meinst nicht den server der einen frontend aus liefert oder weil die macht
sinn im kubernetes cluster zu haben ansonsten verstehe ich die frage nicht
weil wie du schon sagst die eigentliche single page application was auch immer
es ist da kümmert sich der client drum der browser auf den service connected
aber die systeme die das backend aus also die das die das frontend ausliefern das
Macht schon Sinn, die im Cluster zu haben.
Bietet sich ja auch an, die im Cluster zu haben.
Oder du bist so modern und so pleading edge, dass du sowas per, wie nennt sich das, CDN-Edge-Computing, was auch immer machst.
Auf Reddit geht auch keiner unter 100k arbeiten.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich bin sogar in letzter Zeit relativ wenig online.
NoLimit, danke für den Sub.
Was ist deine Meinung zu SCCM?
Ich weiß nicht, für was SCCM steht.
Source Control Management, oder was ist das?
Microsoft System Center Configuration, oh ne, dazu ist meine Meinung, geh mir weg.
Geh mir bloß weg.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, keck Windows, Alter.
Piss dich, Alter.
Damit will ich nix zu tun haben.
Du meinst sowas wie WinGet?
Oder, gib mir auch Scoop, oder Schoko.
Schokolade, Schokolade, oder so.
Ja, ich mein, es liegt in der Natur der Sache, dass die halt deutlich beschissener unter Windows sind, als unter Linux.
Wegen den ganzen Installern und teilweise auch nur grafischen Sachen.
Aber besser als nix.
Was sagst du zu PowerShell?
PowerShell ist nice.
Für Automatisierung.
Aber nix zum interaktiven...
...Auf-Täglich-Nutzen.
Find ich.
Sieht Windows-Admin sicherlich anders aus.
Sehen Windows-Admin sicherlich anders.
Nein, würde ich auf gar keinen Fall benutzen.
Mal blöd gefragt, wenn du eine SaaS-Anwendung deployen würdest,
AP Frontend-Datenbank,
würdest du dieses hosten?
Willst du ne Managed-Datenbank?
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Also willst keine VM und da ne Postgres drauf machen, du willst ne Managed-Datenbank.
Also preis-leistungsmäßig,
würde ich halt sagen, fährst du mit DigitalOcean wahrscheinlich günstiger, als mit Google und Azure.
Die Preise sind dort teilweise echt pepega.
Aber der Kram funzt halt einfach.
Wobei ich denke, DigitalOcean, da hab ich aber persönlich jetzt nicht so viel Erfahrung mit,
würde ich sagen, DigitalOcean funzt halt auch einfach.
Also, wenn's nicht so sehr auf Geld ankommt, find ich Google Cloud nicht schlecht.
Ich sag jetzt mal Google Cloud anstelle von Azure. Azure kannst du genauso verwenden.
AWS wahrscheinlich auch, mit AWS kenn ich mich nicht gut aus.
Ich sag jetzt einfach mal Google Cloud, weil ich in letzter Zeit mehr Google Cloud mache, als Azure.
Und je nachdem, was du vorhast, kannst du das ja auch richtig Cloud-Native machen.
Also je nachdem, wie komplex dein API-Endpoint-Zeug ist.
Entweder startest du die Container einfach nur per Cloud-Run und fertig ist.
Du brauchst kein kubaniertes Cluster, keine Linux4M und nix.
Oder du kannst dir auch ein Autopilot-Kubaniertes Cluster bauen lassen,
je nachdem, wie viele Container-Workloads du hast.
Frontend packst du in irgendeinen CDN.
Und Datenbank kannst du beispielsweise eine Managed Cloud SQL Postgres oder sowas nehmen.
Und dann hast du relativ wenig Sachen, um die du dich kümmern musst.
Kostet natürlich ein bisschen mehr Geld.
Am billigsten ist es auf jeden Fall, du gehst beispielsweise zu Hetzner, holst dir eine Linux4M und machst den Kram selbst.
Dann musst du dich aber auch um OS-Updates kümmern, um irgendwelche Datenbank-Anpassungen
und was man nicht sonst noch alles für Datenbanken braucht.
Nachdem ich von Datenbanken, das ist tatsächlich eines der Themen, von denen ich sehr wenig Ahnung habe,
übelster Noob bin, finde ich ehrlich gesagt Datenbanken als Service irgendwo managt sehr praktisch.
Zumal es da auch mit Backups und allem total easy ist.
Und Snapshots und sowas.
Kannst du im Zweifelsfall über das Webinterface machen.
Hast du schon mal was mit Argo CD gemacht?
Ja, habe ich.
Wie man hier im Stream sieht, im Archiv.
Es ist immer schwierig, da so konkret was zu zu sagen, weil man die jeweilige Anwendung nicht kennt.
Es gibt ja da heute tausend Varianten, was du machen kannst.
Du kannst auch komplett FIFED Cloud Native machen.
Du hast gar keinen Backend, gar keine Backend-AP in dem Sinn mehr.
Du hast noch irgendwelche Cloud Functions.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich finde es teilweise echt übertrieben.
Das macht auch einfache Dinger mega komplex.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es Unsinn, dass es pauschal unsinnig ist.
Aber gegen ne, was weiß ich, .NET, Java, Python, Go, was auch immer, Backend-AP ist eigentlich nichts einzuwenden.
Man kann es mit Cloud Native und Skalierung und allem auch so übertreiben,
dass es keine Sau mal versteht.
Und 50.000 Euro im Monat kostet, ohne dass es irgendjemand benutzt und Geld bringt.
Also, ich finde, man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Hast du das?
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Aber wir haben uns letztens was angeguckt zu Unity.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da Neuigkeiten gibt.
So, ich wollte mir dieses Windows AI Video angucken.
Okay, also, wir kriegen jetzt den Windows 11 Co-Pilot introduced, Leute.
Ich hoffe, Sie weinen uns nicht wieder was vor, wie in der Windows 11 Präsentation.
Warum sind diese Werbevideos immer so anstrengend?
Ich krieg beim Einsetzen der Musik schon irgendwelche Anfälle, ey.
Alter!
Wer macht denn diese Werbevideos immer?
Boah, Paint! Krass!
It's more secure.
Uiuiui.
Also, das ist sicherlich cool animiert und alles.
Aber ich finde diese Werbevideos so anstrengend immer.
Aus den 90er Jahren, die Werbevideos für Software und Hardware.
Die fand ich viel besser.
Die waren immer so unfreiwillig komisch dumm.
Und die hier sind so hipsterpoliert irgendwie.
Und ich fände die übelst anstrengend zu gucken.
By the way, so wirklich AI habe ich jetzt noch gar nicht erkannt.
Ja?
New Outlook?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, hier ist AI, Leute!
AI am Start.
Copilot.
Ja, das ist das, was wir uns letztens angeguckt haben.
Choose the Conversation Style.
Wisst ihr, was mich einfach bei vieler Software heutzutage nervt?
Warum muss das alles aussehen auf dem Desktop,
was die Leute mit Maus und Tastatur bedienen?
Warum muss das alles immer aussehen wie irgendeine billige Tablet-App?
Ich sage nicht, dass es schlecht aussieht.
Es sieht nach heutigen Maßstäben gut aus.
So runde Dinger, Schatten, Kontrast, Animation.
Aber es fühlt sich für mich nicht wie eine Desktop-Anwendung an,
das meiste Zeug.
Das fühlt sich an wie so eine billige Tablet-Anwendung.
Open Spotify.
Okay, dafür habe ich AI gebraucht.
Play something to help me focus.
Das ist wirklich essentiell.
Ohne AI wäre ich komplett aufgeschmissen gewesen, Spotify zu öffnen.
Organize my Windows.
Leute, bis ich Organize my Windows getippt habe,
habe ich mein Windows in die richtige Ecke gezogen.
Turn on Dark Mode.
Witzig, das haben wir auch als eines der ersten Sachen im Stream ausprobiert.
Weil mittlerweile findest du ja in den Windows-Settings nichts mehr.
Das heißt, für sowas ist der AI-Modus wahrscheinlich gar nicht schlecht.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das hier suggeriert,
Windows hätte eine coole Animation beim Umschalten auf Dark Mode.
Also das sieht nicht so aus, ne?
Das ist rein Post-Processing animiert.
Switchen auf Dark Mode sieht ganz unspektakulär ruckelig aus unter Windows.
Ja, dass das eingebaut ist, das finde ich ganz praktisch.
Das ist okay.
Das ist gut.
Letztendlich ist AI dafür auch irgendwo mit am besten geeignet.
Für irgendwelches Text, Ideen, Titel, Texte zusammenfassen,
bisschen umschreiben.
Sätze umschreiben.
Dafür ist AI wirklich gut.
Aber das ist nice, dass das eingebaut ist.
Ich frage mich, ob die damit dann auch irgendein Abo-Modell verkaufen wollen.
So nach dem Motto, sie haben jetzt 20 freie Abfragen.
Für, keine Ahnung, in ihrem Office-Paket sind 20 freie Abfragen.
Der Rest braucht ein Chat-GPT-Abo.
Oder in Windows sind 20 freie Abfragen.
Der Rest braucht ein Office 365 Abo.
Sorry, Microsoft 365 heißt das.
Das ist ja nicht mehr Office 365.
Man kann den Kran noch nicht mal richtig skalieren an der Seite.
Man kann da nichts groß...
All diese Hipster-Musik, die macht mich übelst nervös.
Das ist so schrecklich.
Ich halte diese Werbevideos nicht aus.
Okay, Background-Remover drin.
Nice, das ist gut.
Braucht man immer mal wieder.
Ja, ich bin zu Boomer für diese Sorte Werbevideos.
Windows 11.
Soll ich euch auch mal zeigen, was Windows 11 ist?
Was auch super hip und modern ist.
Passt mal auf, ich zeige euch was.
Das hier.
Das ist auch super hip und modern.
Also vor allem sowas hier.
Das sieht einfach so modern und elegant aus.
Diese Icons, die man hat für Ordner unter Windows.
Ist ja nice, dass man einen AI-Assistent hat.
Aber wie wäre es denn mal beispielsweise mit ein paar gescheiten Icons?
So zur Abwechslung.
Damit könnte man ja vielleicht irgendwas anfangen.
Oder das.
High-Res-Bild hier.
Oder der Drucker.
Ist der nicht auch super modern?
Ist das jetzt im Dark-Mode?
Das hier.
Weil Windows ist so halbe-halbe.
Das ist im Dark-Mode, ja.
Aber nicht alles.
Also das ist im Dark-Mode.
Ach so.
Ja.
Moment.
Das ist ja also.
Das ist jetzt nicht.
Ich habe jetzt gesagt.
Mein Windows.
Also das ist nicht nur in meinem Windows so.
Das ist normal.
Das unter Windows nicht alles im Dark-Mode ist.
Weil das hier kann beispielsweise gar kein Dark-Mode.
Also mein Windows ist im Dark-Mode.
Aber die Ordner-Details, die können kein Dark-Mode.
Und natürlich das Icon-Auswahlmenü auch nicht.
Logisch.
Das kann man von Microsoft ja auch nicht erwarten.
Dass man so ein Fenster dunkel färben kann.
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da.
Vielleicht sollte man das mal.
Sollte man das mal den AI-Copilot fragen.
Das Hintergrundbild hast du auch auf deinem Windows.
Weißt du was noch viel nicer ist als dieses Hintergrundbild?
Das Hintergrundbild.
Und da gibt es ein Hintergrund für jede Tageszeit.
Aber du hast hier.
Hast hier für jede Tageszeit hast du.
Du hast Mittagessen, Pepo.
Du hast Kekses, Pepo.
Du hast Arbeits-Pepo.
Du hast Energy-Booster, Pepo.
Nudeln und Lachs, Pepo.
Das versteht wahrscheinlich auch keiner, der den Stream nicht regelmäßig guckt.
Bügeleisen, Pepo.
Workout, Pepo.
Normaler.
Sonnenaufgang, Frühstücks, Pepo.
Cornflakes, Pepo.
Croissant, Schlafen, Träumen.
Abenddings, YouTube gucken.
Also für jede Jahreszeit auch.
Für jede Jahreszeit auch.
Für jede Tageszeit ein.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir was.
Chat, Chat.
Was haltet ihr von Windows 11 Copilot?
Jetzt wo ihr es gesehen habt.
Also ich sehe mich das schon benutzen.
Vielleicht für irgendwelche Textzusammenfassung oder generiere mir 5 Clickbait Titel für YouTube.
Aber ansonsten für die ganzen anderen Funktionen werde ich es nicht benutzen.
Für was der Bügeleisen, Pepo steht.
Für gar nichts.
Für Hausarbeit.
Für Bügeleisen.
I quit Amazon after 2 months.
And we always talked about it.
Already ripped them.
And I would get like a knot in my stomach.
Okay, das können wir tatsächlich mal angucken, dass es nicht so geil bei Amazon ist, wie man sich das vielleicht denkt.
Aber das wusste ich schon, dass es bei Amazon nicht so geil ist.
Weil man hört eigentlich von, also wenn man sich die Großen anguckt, hört man so von Amazon eigentlich nur das Schlechteste.
Und auch von den anderen Großen ist ja die Verweildauer der Leute nicht so groß.
Gab doch mal irgendeine Statistik, dass die meisten Leute, die bei den Großen, Facebook, Google, Microsoft, Amazon und so arbeiten, dass die im Durchschnitt nur eineinhalb Jahre dabei bleiben.
Oder 1,1 Jahre oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Einfach Pass of Exile 2.
Hoffe, dass es irgendwann demnächst nochmal rauskommt.
Guckt mal, Leute.
Diese Werbevideos aus den 90ern, die waren auch mega schlecht, ja.
Aber die waren nämlich unfreiwillig cringe, dumm und komisch.
Und nicht so Hipster-mäßig.
Angeblich soll Steve Ball mal ja einen Stuhl nach jemand geworfen haben, als er gesagt hat, dass er jetzt zu Google wechselt.
Ja.
Aber danach wurde das ja dementiert.
Er hat gesagt, das ist nie passiert.
Aber zutrauen würde ich es ihm trotzdem.
Du, du, du, du, du.
So, lass uns doch mal schauen.
Warum ist Neatcode...
Haben wir von dem schon mal was geguckt?
Kann ich mich jetzt nicht dran erinnern.
Warum hat Neatcode Amazon gequittet?
Wahrscheinlich, weil Amazon...
Wahrscheinlich, weil Amazon Kackladen ist.
Aber...
Man weiß es ja nicht, ne.
Ich vergaß, Moment.
Wir sind ja auf einer Amazon-Plattform.
Da muss man bestimmt ein bisschen aufpassen, was man sagt, ja.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass Amazon ein Kackladen ist.
Amazon ist bestimmt der allergeilste Arbeitgeber auf der Welt.
Und wir haben immer darüber gesprochen, dass man intensiv sein muss.
Und tatsächlich...
Da war er aber noch ganz schön jung.
Da war er noch nicht im Weltall.
If you ever had to give up friendly in order to have intense,
we would do that.
So if we needed to be intense and combative,
we'd do that before we'd be not intense.
I don't really talk about my personal life on here,
but if you follow the channel, you know that I was unemployed,
then I made this YouTube channel,
then I got into Google and now I quit.
But I never really talked about why I was unemployed in the first place.
Well, the short answer is that after I graduated,
I actually accepted an offer from Amazon
and I worked there for two months and then I quit.
I'll give a bit of backstory.
I grew up with my mom...
Ach so, ich dachte, das ist voll aktuell jetzt mit Amazon.
...two brothers.
My dad had drug problems and pretty much abandoned us.
And I mainly just wanted...
Ich dachte, es geht um Amazon.
...to like help my family.
We were poor and we definitely knew it.
I remember as a kid, I was like playing outside.
And then I fell.
I looked down at my knees.
Playing outside?
...and it was bleeding.
Okay, ich habe auch immer draußen gespielt, wo ich noch klein war.
Das waren aber auch noch andere Zeiten.
Da hat man daheim auch noch keine Computer und Internet
und schon mal gar kein Smartphone.
Da musste man draußen spielen.
Aber sobald ich Computer daheim hatte, war vorbei mit draußen spielen.
And the first thought I had was,
damn, my mom just bought me these pair of jeans
and I already ripped them.
And I would get like a knot in my stomach.
It was the worst feeling.
Now, this isn't a sob story.
I think some people spend their whole lives like looking for a purpose,
but I already had mine.
So, when I was lucky enough to be the first in my family to go to college,
my goal was simple.
Get a degree as quickly as possible,
so I can get a high paying job and then help my family.
And I actually did.
So, ich sag euch jetzt mal der Sinn des Lebens für mich.
Ich möchte in meinem Leben möglichst viel von dem machen,
worauf ich Bock habe
und möglichst wenig machen müssen, was mich abfuckt.
So, das war es eigentlich schon.
Easy.
... I got my CS degree.
I failed some interviews,
but I managed to get an offer from Amazon
where I was supposed to make like 140k a year.
And let me actually prove it to you.
Das ist ja für Ami-Verhältnisse, glaube ich, gar nicht so krass viel, oder?
104.000 oder 140.000, was hat er gesagt?
Ah, 140.000.
Das ist aber für Ami-Verhältnisse, glaube ich, auch gar nicht so krass.
Und dann hat er festgestellt, dass es sackt, bei Amazon zu arbeiten.
Das stelle ich mir direkt nach dem Studium schon ziemlich nach Schock vor.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr träumt die ganze Zeit davon, so nach dem Motto, in dem Bereich zu arbeiten und dann vielleicht sogar bei einem der richtig großen Unternehmen.
Man fängt ja da an und dann ist halt das ein richtiger Kack.
Ja, muss ja auch bei Amazon rennen, ja, wo laufen die Leute weg?
Ist halt schrecklich.
Ich flöte, wenn man neu ist, ne?
Ich meine, wenn du neu in einem Team bist und das Erste, was du gesagt kriegst, ey, wir,
hier läuft, hier läuft Scheiße, halt mal die Klappe und fragt, fragt nix.
So, das ist schon blöd, weil, wie willst du, wenn du neu irgendwo bist, ohne zu fragen, überhaupt reinkommen, ja?
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Just felt like impossible.
My entire life, I never had an experience like this one, I swear.
I felt like I was on fire and I would do anything to make it stop.
And so, I quit.
My thought process was, I'm sure they're gonna fire me.
Anyway, but I'm reasonably smart and reasonably hardworking.
I don't know how long it's gonna take, but I'm pretty sure I'll be able to get another high-paying job one day.
And even if it pays half as much as Amazon did, for me, that's still a lot of money.
But honestly, maybe I was just trying to convince myself.
And the funny thing is, when I actually first sent my resignation email, my manager called me and basically said,
Come on, you don't have to quit.
Warum auch?
Ja, gut, da hätte ich als Manager auch blöd geguckt.
So nach dem Motto, wie, du hörst auf, du hast doch erst letzte Woche angefangen.
But I was like, no, I'm serious, this sucks ass.
And then the next day, my senior manager called me and basically said the same thing.
Somehow, they actually convinced me.
And I was like, okay, maybe I can make things work here.
And a couple days went by, and for the third and final time, I sent my resignation email.
After quitting, I thought things would get better.
They did not.
Whenever I sat at my computer and opened VS Code, I would just get like this intense feeling in my stomach.
And after a while, I just gave up.
Warum? Also so ganz folgen konnte ich ihm jetzt nicht?
Ja.
Also was war jetzt, was war jetzt das Problem?
Also, er ist in ein neues Team gekommen.
Die haben ihm gesagt, wir sind hier ziemlich am Arsch.
Nervt uns nicht.
Okay, ich meine, ich gehe mal davon aus, ich glaube gar nicht, dass es ein wirkliches Skill-Issue ist.
Bei ihm gewesen, sondern es war eher, der ist mit dem Umfeld halt nicht klar gekommen.
Das kann ich persönlich auch nachvollziehen.
Also mir.
Mir gefällt es auch schwer, in einem Umfeld zu arbeiten, wo ich halt den Eindruck habe, dass man irgendwie in so einer komplett, dass die Leute irgendwie so in einer komplett anderen Welt sind so.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein paar Leak-Code-Videos gedreht, aber ich habe das sogar stoppt, weil ich so depressiv war.
Ich war mit Drogen und Alkohol umgekehrt, ich habe den Bong so...
Das eskaliert so schnell, ja.
... so schnell, dass ich es überhaupt nicht mehr fühle.
I was just in shock.
How did this happen to me?
This was not supposed to happen.
It was supposed to be different.
If I was stronger, this would have never happened to me.
If I could just have one more chance, I know I could make things right.
Maybe in another life, I'll make them proud.
I literally...
Das ist ja, ich meine, ist ja noch kein Weltuntergang, oder?
Ich meine, ja, ich verstehe es schon irgendwo, du bist frisch von der Uni, fängst irgendwo deinen vermeintlichen Traumjob an, stellst dich raus, das sind alles Deppen, mit denen du halt in einem Umfeld, mit dem du überhaupt nicht klarkommst, ja, schwer nachzuvollziehen.
So ähnlich interpretiere ich das auch.
Der hat da angefangen, die haben ihm gesagt, nerv nicht, und da saß dann halt rum, war komplett überfordert mit dem, was man ihm vorgesetzt hat.
Was ja auch schwierig ist, so von 0 auf 100 ins kalte Wasser.
Und was ich auch so ein bisschen raushöre, ist, dass er halt mit dem Umfeld überhaupt nicht klargekommen ist.
Und das kann ich nachvollziehen, dass man da echt Bauchschmerzen hat.
Also wenn du den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit sitzt und permanent das Gefühl hast, oder den Eindruck hast, dass du hier nicht hingehörst, so von den Leuten, und das ist unglaublich schwer zu beschreiben.
Es ist ein bisschen so...
Stellt euch vor, irgendwie, ein Freund von euch in der Schule hat Geburtstag, und der lädt euch ein, aber, also, keine Ahnung, ein Freund, der nicht bei euch an die Schule geht, den ihr über irgendwie zwei Ecken kennt, lädt euch zum Geburtstag ein, und beim Geburtstag sitzen halt nur Leute rum, die ihr nicht kennt.
Dann habt ihr auch, ja, da könnt ihr auch sagen, ja, geil, jetzt kann ich mich einfach mal drei Stunden kostenlos vollfressen, aber ihr fühlt euch eigentlich permanent unwohl.
Weil dort nur Leute sind, die ihr nicht kennt, vielleicht komische Leute, wo ihr denkt, Alter, mit denen werde ich nie warm, irgendwelche nervigen Leute, und wenn das halt so ist, muss ja nicht so sein, aber kann auch sein, dass die alle ganz nice sind.
Aber es gibt halt solche Veranstaltungen, auf denen man ist, und wenn sich das so auf der Arbeit jeden Tag anfühlt, dann verstehe ich, dass das Umfeld so unangenehm ist, dass du das nicht aushältst auf Dauer.
Ich habe das mir selbst gedacht. Es klingt kringelig, es zu sagen, aber das ist wirklich so, wie ich es fühlte.
I was at rock bottom, and this lasted for weeks, and it was not getting better, until one day, I made a huge mistake, I went to my fridge, I opened the freezer, I grabbed a piece of tinfoil, I opened it and ate everything inside, it was like five or six tabs of LSD, now it was...
Okay, okay, okay, das eskaliert.
Ich bin jetzt wirklich quickly langsam.
The fuck?
Erstmal Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
The world around me had very noticeably changed.
A school construction project next to where I lived was not really about the school.
It was actually meant to spy on me.
Why?
That's the question I kept asking myself.
Okay, da muss man jetzt aber mal fairnesshalber sagen, da kann jetzt Amazon ja nix dafür.
Amazon mag gerade in diesem Team vielleicht nicht der passende Arbeitgeber für ihn gewesen sein.
Aber das ist so.
Da kann jetzt nur Amazon wirklich nix für.
Warum hat er überhaupt ein fettes Paket LSD in seinem Gefrierschrank?
Ja, das ist die richtige Frage.
Why are people following me?
Why is it that every time I drive, police are following me?
I know that sounds crazy, but here's one that's like...
Das teint...
Das soundet ein bisschen nach Kekaloo.
...a bit believable, at least for like a paranoid person.
In college, I had my only internship...
...at Capital One.
During that time, there was a data breach on their services that were hosted on AWS.
And it was actually intentionally caused by like a former Amazon engineer.
And while I was at Amazon, I would sometimes take like handwritten notes, like about my tasks.
So then I started thinking, oh shit, there's gonna be another breach and Amazon is gonna try to blame it on me.
Why?
I don't know, but I took those notes and I burned the shit out of them.
Now...
I'm not a big crier.
I'm honestly not.
But in this situation, it was so hard to get better, because I just could not stop crying.
Even worse, I couldn't remember anything.
I would get up and walk to the kitchen and be like, wait, what am I doing again?
Wait, how old am I again?
What's my name again?
Wait, didn't I...
Okay, dafür kann aber Amazon jetzt ja wirklich nix.
...a doctor's appointment today?
I was so...
I was so scared that I was just completely losing my mind, but I did not stay down.
Almost every day, I would drive to an empty parking lot and after I was done crying, I would read to myself and I'll actually show you.
Maybe working this particular job caused a little too much anxiety right now, but as I continue, I know pretty soon it will be easier and more manageable.
You can even see the date, last edited August 20, 2020.
I would read these words every single day until one day I could believe them.
Even then, months went by of me doing nothing.
I couldn't eat, I couldn't sleep, or even remember things.
I didn't really...
Ich frage mich jetzt ernsthaft so...
Also, ich weiß halt nicht, ob das jetzt...
Also am Anfang dachte ich noch, es ist halt ein scheiß Umfeld bei Amazon.
Aber es ist halt die Frage, wäre das woanders?
In dem Fall...
So viel besser gelaufen?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was noch zu tun ist, also denke ich, dass ich am 1. Dezember 2020 entschieden habe, okay, ich werde nur jeden Tag ein Leak-Code-Problem lösen, egal was anderes um mich herum passiert.
Und die Konsistenz und die Ergänzung davon hat mir tatsächlich viel geholfen, und literally eine Woche nachdem ich das gemacht habe, habe ich mich wieder ein bisschen normaler angefühlt.
Also dann habe ich angefangen...
Und dann habe ich angefangen, wieder Leak-Code-Videos zu machen, literally eine Woche nachdem ich das gemacht habe.
Es war so ein seltsames Gefühl, so schnell wie...
Ich muss so ein bisschen sauber wieder ein Video machen, wenn ich gerade ein...
...Brain hat, like, come apart, was as quickly as it just came together.
Und I kept at it for a year until I got my first job interview and then job offer since quitting, and it happened to be at Google.
And maybe this is the drugs talking, but ever since then...
It just feels like a dream, like, it doesn't feel real to me anymore.
I feel like every time I...
Ich glaube, da hat sich echt ein bisschen zu viel reingehauen, ne?
...I have to do something hard or something I couldn't do in the past.
I literally feel like somebody else is doing it for me.
Now, I'm not saying that Leak-Code will cure your mental illness, and I'm not a doctor, but if I had to guess, this whole experience of going crazy was probably, like, drug-induced...
Also, ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, also, was...
Was...
Was dem Health auf jeden Fall hilft, ist, kein tiefgefrorenes LSD sich reinschmeißen.
...Cosis, at least from what I know.
Now, I can't tell you exactly how to get into Google.
I can't tell you exactly how to make a lot of money or whatever it is that you want to do.
I wish I could, but I can tell you this.
When you're consistent, never stay down, enjoy what you do, maybe even obsess over it.
And lastly...
...are honest with yourself and a little self-critical.
You tell me, would you want to bet against someone like that?
I wouldn't, and for that reason, I'm never gonna bet against myself.
I'm Navi, and that's my story in my own words.
Okay.
Ja.
Gut, weiß ich nicht, was ich jetzt auch zu sagen soll.
Aber ist ja gut, dass es ihm wieder besser geht.
Und er jetzt wieder hart am Leak-Coden ist.
Das sind...
...Pog-Subscription.
Der macht...
...24-Hours-Lead-Coding-Go.
Ich mach demnächst 24-Hours-Lead-Coding-Kobol.
Und mal gucken, wer mehr Lead ist.
Ja, und am besten auch nicht aus...
Also, am besten gar nicht, und dann keine ganze Tüte aus dem Kühlschrank.
Ach so, mir wurde noch ein anderes Video vorgeschlagen heute.
Die Wahrheit über C++.
Ey, what?
Chat, ich glaub, das müssen wir jetzt noch gucken.
Es ist ja 3 Minuten 16.
Weißt du, dass der live ist?
Unity interessiert mich nicht so sehr.
Wir gucken uns jetzt lieber an die Wahrheit über C++, 3 Minuten 16.
Und mal gucken, ob es wirklich die Wahrheit über C++ ist.
Weil, wie wir alle wissen, gibt es ja nur eine Wahrheit über C++.
Das ist, dass es kacke ist.
A lot of people don't like C++ when compared to its parents, C.
C++ is misunderstood.
Ach ja.
Or is it?
Should you even learn?
C++?
Nein.
C with classes, later renamed to C++, was invented by Jarnay Stroutsup.
Man sollte kein C++ lernen.
Man sollte C++ nur dann benutzen, wenn es halt nicht anders geht.
Zum Beispiel für irgendwelche Microcontroller-Geschichten.
Oder meinetwegen für Unreal Engine in den Reihen oder so, wo du nicht drumherum kommst.
Überall, wo du drumherum kommst, sollte man einfach die Finger lassen von C++.
C++ was invented by Jarnay Stroutsup in 1979.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, so spricht man ihn nicht.
Nicht aus.
... was to design a language in which I could write programs that were both efficient and elegant.
Many languages forced you to choose between the two alternatives.
Since the initial release of the language, C++ has grown substantially while adhering to three core principles.
Haben wir das Video nicht schon mal geguckt?
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
... principles.
There should be no language beneath C++ except assembly.
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Ist es nicht?
Noch mal.
Kenn ich schon.
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
So, welches Video sollten wir uns angucken?
Das von Morpho?
Ich bin sich...
Wow, Alter, hör uns doch laut.
Nicht so laut.
Tja, ihr habt von dem Unity-Skandal gehört.
Wie sie mit einer einzigen Änderung in ihrem Preismodell...
Ja, ich denke, er hält schon See hier.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen...
Max, du hast das ernsthaft so schnell im Wort jetzt gefunden.
Krass.
Ähm...
Das habe ich vergessen, weil ich es sagen wollte.
Ja.
Man darf nicht vergessen, dass nach der Bekanntgabe,
dass man mal sieht, wie toll die eigenen Mitarbeiter
diese Entscheidung finden.
Es gab eine Bombentrohung bei Unity.
Und dann hat sich herausgestellt,
das war von einem Mitarbeiter von Unity.
Also, die scheinen das auch nicht so geil zu finden.
Weil die Existenz...
Ja, jetzt haben sie sich mal wieder entschuldigt.
Wie immer, ja.
Mittlerweile ist ja bei Spiele-Releasen auch schon normal,
dass zu dem Release schon der passende Entschuldigungsletter live geht.
Ab 7 Minuten 51.
Okay.
So.
An diesem Punkt sollte ich euch alle ungefähr abgeholt haben.
Und an diesem Punkt wird sich meine Berichterstattung
von den anderen Medien wahrscheinlich unterscheiden.
Okay.
Denn ich sehe hier ein Gesamtproblem.
Ein Problem, das insgesamt so groß ist, dass man sich nicht mehr so gut erkennt.
Ein Problem, das so groß ist, dass wir uns einfach mittlerweile als ITler drum kümmern müssen.
Unity ist für viele Indie-Studios kein vertrauenswürdiger Partner mehr.
Ja.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Ich habe vor kurzem einen Talk von einem sehr kleinen Studio aus Freiburg gehört,
der Stadt, wo ich aufgewachsen bin.
Und auch wenn nur 10% der Studios betroffen sein sollen,
hat es halt nachhaltig das Vertrauen in die Firma zerstört.
Ja, verständlich.
Woher weiß man, dass das nicht bald wieder passiert?
Nur eben leicht anders.
Das bedeutet aber,
dass alle Spiele,
die man bisher entwickelt hat,
sind nichts mehr wert auf dem Markt.
Noch viel schlimmer.
Ihr müsst neue Projekte in eine andere Engine portieren.
Und das bedeutet,
ihr müsst die Engine,
die ihr dann danach benutzen wollt,
neu lernen.
Komplett.
Und hier kommen wir zu meinem großen Punkt.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also ganz ehrlich,
wenn Spiele schon nennenswert fortgeschritten sind in der Entwicklung,
ich glaube, die wenigsten werden jetzt den Engine-Wechsel dafür machen.
Ich meine, klar,
wenn es einen Mann braucht,
wenn es ein größeres Projekt ist,
wo aber je nachdem,
also kein größeres Projekt wird zwischendrin einen Engine-Wechsel machen.
Eure gesamte Erfahrung.
Aber du musst,
aber ja,
du musst auf jeden Fall neu lernen,
weil das nächste Projekt wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht mehr mit Unity machen.
... in der IT.
Eure Expertise bezieht sich hauptsächlich auf den Tech-Stack,
mit dem ihr arbeitet.
Ja, richtig.
Was ist passiert?
Unity,
also ich versuche das mal zu rekapitulieren.
Ich bin gar nicht sicher,
ob ich das alles aus dem Kopf hinbekomme.
Unity hat gesagt,
sie ändern ihr Lizenzmodell für Unity
und die Leute sollen jetzt ab,
ich glaube, 1.1.2024 auch rückwirkend,
also auch für Spiele,
die schon veröffentlicht wurden vor ein paar Jahren oder so,
ab einer gewissen Anzahl von Downloads,
wohlgemerkt nicht Käufen,
sondern Downloads beziehungsweise Installationen,
Geld an Unity bezahlen.
Und da haben halt viele gesagt,
Unity kann uns mal.
Das kleine Studio meinte,
wir haben bislang alle unsere Projekte mit Unity erstellt.
Ach ja, und das Ganze auf Grundlagen von Statistiken,
die nur Unity kennt.
Wo man nicht genau weiß,
wie diese Werte und Metriken überhaupt zustande kommen.
Geht das überhaupt rechtlich?
Das werden wir noch sehen, ob das geht.
Weil theoretisch betrifft das Microsoft auch
mit dem Game Pass.
Und Microsoft wird einen Scheiß tun,
ihr Unity-Geld zu bezahlen, einfach so.
Und werden es deswegen auch weiterhin tun,
weil wir die Engine gut können.
Anderes Beispiel.
Bei Witcher 3 hat man gemerkt,
dass die Entwickler so allmählich mit ihrer Engine warm wurden
und mit all den Möglichkeiten, die sie eben anbietet,
als das zweite DLC von Witcher 3 veröffentlicht wurde.
Man wirft also nicht nur
die komplette Arbeit weg, wie im Fall von Cult of the Lamb,
sondern auch die Erfahrung, wenn man die Engine wechselt.
Stellt euch vor, die Programmiersprache Java.
Macht so etwas und ihr seid von Java abhängig.
All eure Projekte sind...
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Oracle macht ja viele merkwürdige Dinger.
Ich meine, Oracle sind die ersten,
denen ich auch so einen Move zutrauen würde.
Zum Glück sind die meisten ja heute auf OpenJDK
und können ein bisschen mehr auf Oracle scheißen.
Aber Oracle ist ein gutes Beispiel, ja.
In Java.
Ihr habt eure Assets im Java Store, aka eure Module
und plötzlich verlangt Java Gebühren
für zum Beispiel jeden Endpoint-Aufruf.
Wenn ihr dann umsteigen müsst auf eine andere Sprache,
einen anderen Tech-Stack etc.,
dann kostet euch das mindestens drei Jahre Berufserfahrung,
für die man ja auch bezahlt wird auf dem Arbeitsmarkt.
Und so abwegig ist das Ganze tatsächlich gar nicht.
Schauen wir uns ganz kurz die Web-Frontend-Frameworks an.
Richtig weit verbreitet sind derzeit Angular.
Drei Jahre ist natürlich ein bisschen so pauschal.
Ich meine, je nachdem, was du halt im Gaming-Bereich machst.
Es gibt sicherlich einige Sachen, die sich transferieren lassen.
Aber ja, es ist schon was grundsätzlich anderes.
Und React.
React ist von Meta, Angular ist von Google.
Sie sind hauptsächlich deshalb so,
so weit verbreitet, weil sie gute Maintenance haben.
Sprich, weil Google und Meta dahintersteht
und diese Frameworks immer weiterentwickelt und verbessert.
Aber auch Dart und Flutter ist von Google.
Dart und Flutter, die ursprünglich mal für Apps entwickelt wurden,
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht,
vielleicht hat hier jemand von euch,
Pyth Haddon, im Chat eine Idee.
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht,
warum Flutter nicht auf Go, sondern auf Dart aufbaut.
Aber es kommt auch immer mehr für Webentwicklung.
Wenn jetzt Google sich entscheidet,
auf Dart und Flutter umzusteigen
und Angular nicht mehr weiterzuentwickeln,
oder zumindest sehr viel weniger,
dann würde es früher oder später vermutlich verschwinden.
Vermutlich nicht für Dart und Flutter.
Naja, man sieht es ja in manchen Projekten.
Guckt euch mal Terraform an.
Und da war das nicht so schlimm wie bei Unity.
Terraform gibt es jetzt auch einen größeren Fork.
Ich bin immer noch ein bisschen skeptisch,
ob das alles so auf Dauer wird.
Aber okay, schauen wir mal.
Das passiert immer mal wieder,
dass es größere Lizenzänderungen gibt.
Und das macht auch immer mal wieder Probleme.
Angular ist komplett Open Source.
Flutter, da bin ich ehrlich,
ich schätze die Entwickler würden dann eher
in Richtung React oder Vue abwandern.
Bevor Dart und Flutter so groß ist wie Angular,
wird es nämlich noch eine ganze Weile dauern.
Aber diese Gefahr besteht durchaus.
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr einen neuen Job sucht,
ist es normal, dass sich euer Tech-Stack ändert.
Aber genau deswegen sind ITler so unfassbar teuer
auf dem Fachmarkt.
Weil sie in den doch teils sehr unterschiedlichen Tech-Stacks
erstmal noch eingelernt werden müssen.
Klar, die Sprache bleibt dieselbe.
Und die Frameworks sind grundsätzlich vielleicht
sogar sehr ähnlich.
Aber diese kleinen Tricks, diese Lifehacks,
mit denen man eben besonders effizient etwas tut,
die Bibliotheken, an die man sich...
Das kommt mit der Erfahrung in dem jeweiligen Bereich.
In dem jeweiligen Gebiet, ja.
Das stimmt schon.
... das Ökosystem gewöhnt hat,
all das fällt einfach weg.
Und das kommt oft erst eigentlich
nach Jahren wieder voll zurück.
Ob ich jetzt ein Asset im Unity Store kaufe
oder ein Asset im Unreal Engine Store,
macht einen großen Unterschied.
Bei Unity programmier ich C-Sharp,
bei Unreal Engine programmier ich C++.
Ja, leider.
Das sind andere Sprachen.
Das gilt übrigens natürlich auch,
wenn nicht sogar besonders,
für die Sys-Admins unter euch.
Wenn ihr mit Kubernetes arbeitet
und plötzlich könnt ihr das nicht mehr benutzen,
weil sie irgendwas an ihrem Pricing-Modell gemacht haben,
was es komplett zu teuer macht,
dann ist das ziemlich schmerzhaft.
Wenn euer ganzes Unternehmen mit AWS arbeitet,
also der Amazon Cloud,
und plötzlich kommen Änderungen bei Amazon,
die unfassbar ungünstig für euch sind
und die euch zu Azure zwingen,
dann sind das Kosten.
Das stimmt.
Das ist wahnsinnig viel Zeit.
Ja.
Das haben wir nicht von Amazon für euch bezahlt.
Wir haben also in unserem Beruf...
Das ist tatsächlich auch was,
was denke ich an vielen Stellen unterschätzt wird,
dass dieser Trend Multi-Cloud
und ein bisschen Anwender-unabhängig,
das kommt ja jetzt gerade so etwas zögerlich auf,
aber ganz gelöst bekommt man das Problem nicht,
weil gerade die Cloud-Hersteller auch sehr darauf spekulieren,
dass du eben in ihrem Ökosystem bleibst
mit dem, was sie anbieten.
Und so ein kompletter Cloud-Anbieter-Wechsel
ist natürlich schwierig,
umso mehr Spezialitäten du vom jeweiligen Cloud-Anbieter benutzt.
Benutzt du zum Beispiel
irgendeinen selbst installierten RapidMQ als Message-Dienst,
kein Problem.
Benutzt du Google PubSub,
wechselst du nicht einfach mal zu Azure...
Wie heißt das bei Azure?
EventBus, glaube ich.
Ein inhärentes Risiko,
dass unser Wissen einfach teilobsolid wird.
Und das haben wir selbst eigentlich nur geringfügig in der Hand.
Das stimmt.
Ich muss euch aber ehrlich sagen,
ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich meine, unabhängig davon,
dass das scheiße ist, was Unity macht
und auch das mit dem Terraform-Folk und alles,
und dass es blöd ist,
wenn richtig tolle Sachen auf einmal
in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwinden.
Es passiert laufend.
Vor ein paar Jahren hat jeder,
ganz am Anfang,
hat jeder so etwas wie CFEngine
für Server-Automatisierung verwendet.
Also, nach irgendwelchen eigenen Skripts.
CFEngine, weiß nicht,
ob das jemand von euch mal benutzen musste.
Danach kamen so etwas wie Chef und Puppet.
Dann kam Ansible.
Mittlerweile sind wir eigentlich so weit,
dass man Ansible auch schon fast nicht mehr braucht.
Je nach Infrastruktur natürlich.
Dass man Ansible auch schon nicht mehr braucht.
Dass der Trend eindeutig hingeht
in möglichst statische Configs
und Infrastruktur wegschmeißen,
Infrastruktur neu bauen.
Mit Terraform oder irgendwelchen
anderen Professionierungssachen.
Also, das ist permanent im Fluss.
Und wenn ich jetzt super krass
mich mit Ansible auskenne,
oder wenn ich mal super krasser
Puppet-Experte gewesen bin,
auch gelitten.
Aber trotzdem,
muss man sagen,
es sind zwar komplett unterschiedlich paar Sachen,
aber so ein bisschen Transfer
kann man da schon machen.
Ja, Terraform gibt es jetzt ja auch.
Open Tofu habe ich letztens gesehen.
Ist ja Fork.
Aber das geht mit dem Job einher.
Dass permanent neue Sachen dazu kommen.
Und andere Sachen obsolet werden.
Kann man den Fork schon verwenden, ja.
Nicht besser,
wenn wir uns kleinere Bibliotheken etc.
anschauen.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch sogar noch
an den Vorfall mit Discord.py.
Wenn unabhängige Entwickler einfach
keine Zeit mehr für ihre Freizeitprojekte haben,
keine Lust mehr auf das Projekt haben,
oder...
Ich erinnere mich an Lock4j.
... das wegfallen,
dann sterben viele...
Okay, anderer Punkt.
Er meint was anderes.
Aber es ist auch eine Library gewesen,
die ja, glaube ich, von irgendwie
zwei Maintainern gepflegt wird oder sowas.
... schicken.
Die ganze Firma bauen aber
auf diesen kleinen Bibliotheken.
Und wie wir schon bei
Sicherheitslücken gelernt haben,
ist das von Zeit zu Zeit ein ziemlich
wackeliges Konstrukt.
Das stimmt.
In der Fachsprache läuft das übrigens
alles unter Dependency Management.
Also dem Management von Abhängigkeiten.
Im Grunde sind ja eure Bibliotheken
Zulieferer für euch.
Unity Engine ist ein Zulieferer
für die Spielestudios.
Und ihr kennt das Ganze vielleicht für
NPM zum Beispiel unter der PackageLock.json.
Möchte man hier wirklich...
NPM install is even is odd.
... gründlich sein,
dann müsste man jedes Modul prüfen.
Und eigentlich, wenn sie wegfallen,
die freiwilligen Entwickler,
selbst die Weiterentwicklung garantieren.
Das gilt dann aber auch für transitive Abhängigkeiten.
Ja gut,
JavaScript ist jetzt halt schon
das krasseste Beispiel ever dafür.
Weil in JavaScript hast du ja
eine simple Command Line
Node Projekte.
Haben irgendwie 800
MB Node Modules
und sowas drin.
JavaScript ist da wirklich schon extrem.
Und was man sagen muss, Rust ist da auch
ziemlich extrem. In Rust gibt's auch
für jeden Furz
Packages.
Und das ist da auch ganz normal.
... das und das wiederum
nutzt das. Wenn ich jetzt
Docker sicher weiter benutzen möchte,
muss ich mich darum kümmern, dass Docker
weiter genutzt wird, dass diese Bibliothek
weiter genutzt wird und dass deren Bibliothek
auch weiter genutzt wird.
Das ist natürlich schlicht unmöglich.
Da viele Projekte nicht mal sagen,
welche Abhängigkeiten sie haben. Und wir am Ende
sogar beim Betriebssystem selbst
landen. Und wenn wir uns dann
einem Projekt wie Unity verschreiben,
das natürlich auch nicht Open Source
ist, dann haben wir natürlich keine
Möglichkeit. Das ist natürlich das
eigentliche Problem bei wirklich großen bekannten
Open Source Projekten.
Wenn da irgendwas ist und da
die Millionen drinnen stecken,
ist die Chance
zumindest größer, dass sich irgendjemand
findet, der das
übernimmt. Mal gucken,
wie sich der Terraform Fork weiterentwickelt.
Wir wissen es ja nicht. Vielleicht schläft es jetzt auch einfach
nach ein paar Monaten wieder ein.
... dem Ganzen zu beugen. Auch
wenn es eigentlich unser gesamtes Geschäftsmodell
zerstören kann oder
sogar tut und unser
angesammeltes Wissen zumindest zu einem
Teil überflüssig werden lässt.
Mitbestimmungsrecht wäre natürlich toll,
aber das hatten ja nicht mal die eigenen
Entwickler von Unity. Und das
ist wahnsinnig schade. Aber auch
für mich ist Unity kein guter Partner
mehr. Ich habe ja schon Tutorials zu Unreal
Engine 4 gemacht. Das ist zumindest
eine Alternative. Aber
man muss es trotzdem neu lernen.
Ah ja, das stimmt schon.
Das ist ein allgemeines Problem.
Auch kein neues in dem Sinn. Man hat es bei Unity
wieder gesehen. Letztendlich
gehört es irgendwie mit dabei.
Das Zeug verschwindet und
ein neues dabei kommt. Kennst du das
hier? Ähm,
ja. Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist, das ist,
das ist das Zeug, das
über irgendwelche Post-Install
Scripts in
NPM-Packages Sachen installiert werden können, oder?
Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Das Ding ist halt, dass
es wird wahrscheinlich noch
Jahre dauern. Also ich bin nicht in der
Spieleentwicklung drin. Das ist auch kein Thema, was mich groß
interessiert.
Aber ich gehe halt mal davon aus, dass es noch Jahre
dauern wird, selbst wenn
das viel Zuspruch bekommt,
bis Bodo
auf einem Niveau ist
und vor allem
Ökosystem hat, wie Unity.
Wenn überhaupt jemals.
Also sowohl vom Funktionsumfang
her, als auch von den
tausend Sachen
drumherum.
Es ist natürlich
eine sinnvolle Sache
und für alle Beteiligten besser, wenn man auch
eine Open Source Engine aufbaut.
Generell, was
eigentlich, egal was es ist,
immer von Vorteil ist.
Deswegen verstehe ich auch nicht, warum
Mojo, dieser neue, kompilierte
Python-Verschnitt,
so einen großen Anklang findet, obwohl er
nur als
ja, irgendwann machen wir ihn mal Open Source
geplant ist. Das ist halt nichts.
Wenn du dir überlegst, was
Unity ausgibt, wahrscheinlich fürs Weiterentwickeln
ihrer Sachen.
50.000 Euro im Monat nix.
Davon kannst du 10 Entwickler bezahlen.
Also, und das
mit 10 Entwicklern, hast du halt
bisschen Probleme da
aufzuholen.
Aber ich sag ja
nicht, dass es was Schlimmes ist. Ich meine nur,
es ist auf jeden Fall, also ich find's ja gut.
Aber, ich weiß nicht, es wird natürlich
eine ganze Weile dauern,
bis sie soweit sind.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich kenn mich damit nicht.
Also, explizit mit Game-Entwicklung.
Hab ich keine Ahnung.
Das ist natürlich schon ein Vorteil,
wenn alle da was contributen können.
Wobei das auch nicht immer nur
jetzt
so von Vorteil ist.
Ja, das kann auch ganz schön Arbeit machen.
Schwer zu sagen, also.
Es wär auf jeden Fall cool.
Also noch ne ordentliche,
gerade was Game-Engines
angeht. Ich weiß nicht,
wie das bei Unity, äh wie das bei
Unreal ist.
Also ich geh mal davon aus,
Teile von Unreal sind Open-Source, aber wahrscheinlich
die eigentliche Core-Engine-Sache
nicht.
Oder ist Unreal sowas mit
es ist nicht wirklich
Open-Source im Sinne von
tja, wie das die Open-Software
Foundation oder wie auch immer definiert hat, aber
man darf reingucken, als
Auserwählter. Keine Ahnung, wie das bei
Unreal läuft.
Gibt ja so Lizenzmodelle, so.
Es ist eigentlich, es ist keine Open-Source
im klassischen Sinne, aber,
äh, mit dem passenden Lizenzvertrag
darfst du reingucken, so.
Ist die
Open-Source? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Wenn du das sagst, ich hab mich damit,
ich beschäftig mich wenig mit Spieleentwicklung,
ich, es ist einfach ein Gebiet,
das interessiert mich nicht. Ich spiele ab und zu
mal Spiele, ja klar, aber selbst
Spiele entwickeln hat mich noch nie groß interessiert.
Man kann Unreal downloaden, weißt?
Äh, das kannst du
vergessen. Ich glaub,
eines der größten Probleme,
was ist eigentlich
aus der, aus dem
Amazon-Fork von der CryEngine
geworden? Das hat auch niemand
interessiert, oder?
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie das heißt. Irgendwas,
Holzfäller oder sowas hieß das
Ding noch. Lumberjack, ja.
Oder so ähnlich.
Star Citizen ist auf, auf Cry,
CryEngine, ja, doch.
Ziemlich das einzige,
was mir einfällt, was irgendwie CryEngine
verwendet.
Außer halt Crytek-Spiele selbst.
Ist es das?
Ist mir neu.
Aber wie gesagt, Spiele-Engine-Entwicklung
und so, ich verfolge das nicht. Spiele-Entwicklung
juckt mich nicht. Nichts, was mich
persönlich groß interessiert.
So, Leute, ich muss jetzt ins Bett.
Morgen
früh muss ich
sieben Uhr irgendwie
in dem Dreh aufstehen, Frankfurt fahren, da hab ich ja schon
wieder Bock drauf, Alter. Nachdem das mit der
Bahn so gut funktioniert hat am Freitag,
wird's richtig Bock morgen nochmal.
Far Cry nutze ich, ja, das ist ja logisch.
Ach, Moment, du meinst das neue Far Cry?
Nee, glaub ich nicht.
Ich glaub die neuen, nee, nee,
nee, nee, nee, ich glaub die neuen Far Crys sind nicht
CryEngine. Das erste.
Aber ich glaube
danach nicht mehr. Ich glaub,
ich bin mir gar nicht, ich glaub das zweite auch schon nicht
mehr. Das erste?
Gut, Crysis.
Wobei, es gab schon lange kein neues Crysis
mehr, ne, das letzte
auch schon wieder ein paar Jährchen her.
Gut, die haben jetzt ja Hunt Showdown,
das macht ja wohl ganz gut Kohle.
Erstmal kein neues Crysis geben.
Ich hab,
ich ja persönlich der Meinung bin, dass die,
dass das
erste Crysis das beste war.
Und das erste Far Cry
war auch mega.
Ich persönlich mochte allerdings Far Cry
3 auch noch. Die anderen sind auch
gar nicht so übel, aber es ist einfach zu viel
Aufguss davon. Ja, also Vierer und so.
Aber Far Cry
3 war auch nice.
Ich weiß, mein Fahrrad ist aber nicht angekommen.
Laut
DHL ist es jetzt zum dritten
Mal schon in der Zustellbasis
oder sowas. Echt?
Ja gut.
Elder Scrolls 6 wurde auch
angekündigt vor einer ganzen Weile.
Okay. Leute,
wir hören uns. Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.